madame et monsieur directeur mes chers
collègues je vous nous accueillons ce
matin de spécialistes des questions
spatiales
madame isabelle sourbès-verger chercheur
au cnrs et monsieur xavier pasco
directeur de la fondation pour la
recherche stratégique que je remercie
tous les deux pour leur disponibilité de
prison qu'en bons regrette de ne pas
pouvoir être présent ce matin une vous
prie de bien vouloir nous en excuser
l'année qui vient de s'écouler a été
particulièrement difficile pour la
politique spatiale européenne
le premier lancement d'ariane 6 a été
reportée de deux ans vega a connu deux
échecs la mission exomars a manqué sa
fenêtre de tir
les états unis et la chine ont réalisé
deux tiers des lancements orbitaux
réussi en 2020 creusant l'écart dans un
marché marqué par l'essor des
constellations de satellites
le succès médiatique de l'astronaute
thomas pasquet semble être l'arbre qui
cache la forêt alors que le secteur
spatial est soumis à une concurrence
croissante de l'europe que l'europe
subit de plein fouet symboliquement au
moins la chine a marqué les esprits en
posant récemment un rover sur mars
quant aux états unis leader mondial
incontesté ils reviennent en force
depuis quelques années tiré vers le haut
par les technologies de méthodes du
space du new space les acteurs privés
soutenus par la nasa sont désormais en
première ligne et peu de gens croyaient
en space x
il y a encore quelques années force est
de constater que le succès est bien là
tandis que les enjeux économiques
s'exacerbe la militarisation de l'espace
suscite aussi des inquiétudes les
dangers pour nos satellites civils et
militaires sont multiples en conséquence
de la prolifération des objets spatiaux
et du risque évidemment de manoeuvre
inamical susceptible de devenir plus
fréquent de voir plus offensive dans un
contexte de dégradation globale du
contexte stratégique pour mieux traiter
ces vulnérabilités et la france a décidé
en 2019 la création d'un commandement de
l'espace au sein de l'armée qui a changé
de nom quels sont aujourd'hui les enjeux
stratégiques de l'accès à l'espace un
rapprochement sino russe est il à
craindre dans le domaine spatial comme
dans d'autres domaines d'ailleurs dans
ce contexte l'europe peut-elle encore
éviter la relégation
je rappelle à tous que cette audition
est captée et retransmise sur le site
internet du sénat monsieur xavier pasco
vous êtes spécialiste de la politique
spatiale des états unis
vous propose de vous exprimer en premier
si vous le souhaitez vous voulez bien et
ensuite madame isabelle sourbès-verger
traitera des enjeux stratégiques au
niveau mondial ce directeur vous avez la
parole pour une quinzaine de minutes si
vous voulez bien et ensuite madame
et puis j'aurai l'occasion évidemment de
de proposer à nos collègues de vous
interroger sur tous les points
extrêmement intéressant de la politique
spatiale
merci beaucoup je vous laisse la parole
voilà est-ce qu'avec le masque ou mardi
donc merci donc de m'inviter m'exprimer
sur cette question des enjeux
stratégiques de l'espace vous avez je
pense très très clairement résumé les
grands enjeux qui nous font face
moi je vais essayer surtout de vous
donner une grille de lecture qui est
celle du lhs de l'observateur et avec en
essayant de centrer sur des constats en
fait l'activité spatiale aujourd'hui et
multiforme et je voudrais me me sens
très sûr des grands constats d'abord
vous en avez parlé l'intensification de
l'activité en orbite
ça c'est très très frappant pour nous
qu'ils observent mon espace avec ma
collègue depuis pas mal de temps
c'est la grande grande différence avec
les étangs de nos donne au début
j'allais dire on a aujourd'hui dans tous
les domaines civil commercial militaire
une intensification jamais vu en fait on
a des ordres de grandeur de différences
en termes d'occupation de l'espace juste
un chiffre et je pense it et je pense qu
isabelle pour y revenir mais 1271
satellite lancé en 2000 doit dans le
seul mois de mars 2021 plus de
satellites lancés que dans toute l'année
2016 ce sont des chiffres frappants bien
évidemment ça concerne les petits
satellites des satires de toutes tailles
mais on sent que l'activité s'est accrue
avec évitement une grosse part des états
unis ça c'est le deuxième constat les
états unis l'activité spatiale est
encore aujourd'hui très largement
américaine
sur 3300 satellites opérationnels en
orbite y en à peu près 1900 qui sont
américains et ça c'est quand même très
très frappant aujourd'hui la chine à 412
quelque chose comme ça la russie un peu
plus d'un peu plus de 170 donc les les
différences sont très fortes et
effectivement vous avez parlé d'un
retour des etats-unis dans le jeu c'est
vraiment ce que l'on ce que l'on
constate avec une place prépondérante
pour ce new space effectivement et cette
activité j'y reviendrai qui est liée
aussi et de la rencontre de l'espace et
du monde digital du monde du numérique
35% des satellites opérationnels en
orbite aujourd'hui son super six et si
on prend le simplement les syndics de
plus de 50 kg c'est plus de 55%
donc on est vraiment aujourd'hui dans
une espèce de des sorts inédit de cette
activité
alors donc à ce titre on voit bien que
on est encore dans un environnement qui
est un environnement de deux rapports de
force qu'ils soient civils qu'ils soient
commerciales qu'ils soient militaires et
ça j'y reviendrai aussi c'est parti
hurle de l'esp l'activité spatiale est
partie prenante de posture politique et
je voudrais insister sur deux points
principaux
pour éventuellement susciter des
questions d'abord les évolutions des
usages militaires de de l'espace d'un
côté qui amène aujourd'hui à des
discussions qui est ce qu'il reste
difficile au plan international
et puis ce dont j'ai parlé un petit peu
avant la convergence à laquelle on
assiste en fait depuis plusieurs années
entre technologies spatiales et
technologies de l'information du digital
du numérique et ça donne lieu à des
concurrences vivre qui sont très
structurante en réalité pour les
rapports internationaux aujourd'hui les
rapports évidemment en termes de
compétitivité industrielle par
l'établissement de normes etc
mais là aussi j'y reviendrai en plus ces
développements dans commerciaux ont
aussi des impacts en matière de sécurité
et de défense
donc on a des choses qui se recoupent
qui se boucle et donc les enjeux
stratégiques aujourd'hui ce se forme de
multiples manières dans les différents
domaines mais se rencontrent tous donc
le lien espace militaire c'est en fait
constamment renforcé espace entre espace
et défense est en fait constamment
renforcé au cours des années alors on le
sait en france avec la dépendance
croissante des forces armées
à vis des systèmes spatiaux ce lien
n'est évidemment pas nouveau mais il
s'est vraiment renforcer au fil des
décennies un petit retour sur l'histoire
l'espace est d'abord née du militaire ça
on le sait peut finalement on a l'image
de d'apollo de conquête lunaire de
prendre habité mais la réalité est en
fait que l'espace est née du fait
nucléaire en réalité l'espace est né de
la nécessité des deux blocs et je
m'attarderai pas sur ce sujet mais il
est important parce que ça trace une
généalogie direct de pouvoir gérer cette
relation nouvelle stratégique bipolaire
voir ce surveillant mutuellement et on a
aujourd'hui depuis ce temps la
constitution d'une énorme industrie aux
états unis en union soviétique
évidemment à l'époque avec une poursuite
patiente de programmes spatiaux très
coûteux qui se sont constamment
améliorées qui existe encore aujourd'hui
c'est ce que moi j'appelle l'espace
stratégie qui pourrait et la nouveauté
alors là c'est pas ces dernières années
c'est plutôt ces dernières décennies
quand on a changé le contexte
géostratégique on s'est aperçu que
l'espace pouvaient aussi servir sur le
champ de bataille et donc on a ajouté
des systèmes nouveaux qui sont devenus
finalement des condition sinequanone
pour faire fonctionner armée moderne
la première guerre du golfe c'est en
fait la date des mois ce que j'appelle
l'espace au service du champ de bataille
l'espace opératif avec les munitions
guidées par le gps avec la possibilité
de suivre des missiles à courte portée
des cibles mobiles etc
donc l'espace est entré au delà de
l'espace stratégie qui est entré dans
une ère de d'utilisation opérationnelle
en fait et ça ça a créé des conditions
un peu nouvelles y compris sur la
stabilité du milieu spatial lui-même et
sur le fait que désormais d'un espace
pouvait être perçu considéré comme une
cible par les par les aides par les
opposants et ça induit en fait des
réflexions qu'on voit aujourd'hui
prendre forme
et puis les attentats de 2001 alors ça
c'est très américain
ce que je vous dis là c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est traduit
essentiellement une vision américaine
est bien l'espace au delà même de son
application sur le champ de bataille
c'est quelque chose qui est un outil de
sécurité désormais c'est un outil de
sécurité qui dépasse le seul fait
militaire est ce que j'appelle l'espace
sécuritaire et donc
ça devient pour un certain nombre de
grandes puissances les états unis en
premier lieu je vous ai dit qu'il
reposait beaucoup sur un système spatial
eu assez pléthorique et bien ça devienne
vulnérabilité c'est perçu comme une
vulnérabilité possible comme une
infrastructure critique ce qu'ils
appellent un national weiter interest un
intérêt vital nationale et à ce titre là
et bien conséquence j'allais dire
presque logique on arrive à une
quatrième r peut-être qui est ce que
j'appelle moi l'espace contrôler mais
c'est à dire que l'idée c'est
qu'effectivement il faut développer des
moyens des systèmes peut être des outils
juridiques qui permettent de les
utiliser des systèmes qui permettront de
protéger les satellites de savoir ce qui
se passe dans l'espace d'avoir une image
de la situation spatiale tout ça
aujourd'hui c'est ça la dynamique
militaire et cette dynamique militaire
propre aux etats unis c'est vrai
commence en fait à être je dirais
transposer dans d'autres pays on voit
bien que l'outil militaire moderne
aujourd'hui ne sait plus se passer de
moyens spatiaux ne sait plus se passer
de la nécessité de la maîtrise de
l'information et le moyen spatiale est
une étape est une clé de cette notion de
maîtrise de l'information que ce soit la
collecte de données sa transmission sa
dissémination tout ça aujourd'hui fait
que l'espace devient une infrastructure
au sens propre critique et donc qui
donne lieu à concurrence éventuellement
la nécessité de protection etc
et ça c'est mon deuxième point c'est
cette notion d'infrastructures elle est
renforcée par le fait qu'on voit
aujourd'hui
l'autre point qui me qui me qui me
paraît très important qu'on voit
aujourd'hui cette convergence très très
fort accélérer en fait entre moyens
spatiaux de moins en moins cher de plus
en plus industrialisés et l'industrie du
numérique qui est génératrice de revenus
de ressources pour le spatial et trouve
dans les spéciales un outil parmi
d'autres mais un outil à son service
alors évidemment ça c'est très très là
encore déjà lady retrait américain mais
pas seulement
on a désormais finalement
des technologies spatiales qui emprunte
de plus en plus à une culture extérieurs
à la communauté spatiale c'est ce qu'on
appelle une news press aux états unis
qu'est ce que c'est que le new space
c'est difficile à définir c'est un
mouvement proprement américain néanmoins
je dirais que c'est d'abord la rencontre
de processus technologiques de mode
d'industrialisation à d'exploitation
commerciale nouveau c'est aussi
l'utilisation de méthodes de
technologies d'équipements qui sont
développés pour partie en dehors du
secteur spatial donc avec une autre
approche une autre culture industrielle
éventuellement et sa matérialise
parfaitement cette rencontre entre
spatiale et digital ça reste un
phénomène d'origine américaine mais à
vocation universelle c'est structurant
et ses producteurs de vin d'un cadre
général de fonctionnement nos sociétés
modernes
ce soit dans le cadre de l'industrie de
de l'utilisation des usages aussi qui
sont générateurs de normes qui sont
générateurs de j'allais dire de la
régulation qui évidemment un poids
politique énorme dans les rapports de
force internationaux qui s'établiront
dans ces domaines et là évidemment on ne
peut éviter de parler à nouveau des
états unis même si isabelle y reviendra
peut-être d'autres puissances peuvent
avoir cette ambition
alors avec des moyens différents
peut-être avec un point de départ qui
est bien dire plus tardif mais on peut
s'interroger sur aujourd'hui comment la
chine par exemple effectivement aborde
cette question que ce soit pour sa
sécurité nationale d'ailleurs même que
soit aussi plus largement pour son
développement économique et donc cette
industrialisation si vous voulez
s'appuie peut s'appuyer ça c'est ça la
nouveauté pour l'espace l'espace peut
trouver dans ce secteur aval très
valorisant de haute valeur ajoutée des
ressources et des financements et c'est
ce qu'on voit se passer aujourd'hui
havre être des accords récents qui ont
été passés entre des entreprises du new
space du secteur spatial et des
entreprises des gaffes à dudu qui par
exemple mise énormément sur le cloud et
on voit bien l'intérêt mutuel qui
commence à se construire entre ce type
d'entreprises encore récemment un accord
vient d'être signé entre par exemple
spécifique google par exemple pour le
club donc on voit bien que la chacun
trouve dans l'autre un soutien
et une connectivité pour ce qui concerne
également et une clientèle j'allais dire
un débouché à val valorisant pour ce qui
concerne les les filières définir
spatiale alors on retrouve là évidemment
l'impact de la domination américaine
pour c'est pour ces marchés qui dope
l'espace avec une convergence d'intérêts
entre secteur privé et objectifs
gouvernementaux parce qu'il ne faut pas
effectivement penser qu'il s'agit juste
une sorte de privatisation de l'espace
tout cela s'intègre aussi dans je dirais
dans des objectifs politiques plus
larges qui sont des objectifs politiques
normatif qui sont des objectifs
politiques qui ont trait à la en fait à
la construction des rapports de force
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
et depuis elle ça je suis
particulièrement les états unis
évidemment c'est quelque chose qu'on a
vu entrer en jeu je dirais depuis plus
de 20 ans c'est quelque chose qui a été
patiemment construit avec la
reconversion de cet investissement
public considérable qui a été fait dans
le domaine militaire pour en faire un
outil commercial un outil de
compétitivité industrielle
un outil qui soutiendrait cette
industrie de l'information qui était
naissante dans les années 90 2000 et je
dirais que c'est les graines qui ont été
semées à cette époque bien il ya une
forme de récolte aujourd'hui se rappelle
le new space c'est ce qu'on appelle
toutes ces nouvelles entreprises qui
fleurissent et qui ont finalement
construit avec l'autorité
gouvernementale avec l'acteur public un
rapport tout à fait nouveau qui
permettent en fait d'avoir un bénéfice
mutuel et donc il faut il faut pas je
dirais l'erreur à faire serait de dante
agoniser acteurs publics acteurs privés
non je crois que on est dans une autre
démarche et c'est ça qui est que nous
européens sans doute nous devons
regarder avec beaucoup d'attention
donc ça bouleverse le jeu se met
l'accent sur l'industrialisation sur des
volumes d'activité inédit nombre
d'objets des services offerts etc qui
trouvent une industrie une industrie à
balles puissantes capables de valoriser
ses investissements donc on a désormais
le regard d'ailleurs qui est porté sur
l'espace d'abord c'était large y est
c'est un regard qui est porté qui s'est
décalé un petit peu je trouve
pour nous qui regardent ion l'espace et
qui écoutent ils ont un peu ce qui se
disait sur les questions spatiales il ya
vingt ans même trente ans maintenant
ce qui frappe moi ce qui me frappe aux
états unis notamment mais pas seulement
on commence à voir ça aussi dans
d'autres pays c'est qu'on parle de
l'espace compte d'une infrastructure
comme d'une commodity comme on dit c'est
en fait une infrastructure parmi
d'autres qui va être au service d'une
économie plus large que la seule
économie spatiale alors ça c'est tout à
fait nouveau parce que c'est induits et
bien évidemment des processus de
décision différent des jugements
différents des approches différentes et
aussi je dirais une place une
recomposition du secteur industriel et
éventuellement de la place de des grands
industriels des nouveaux industriels
dans dans la mise en place de cet
ensemble un peu composite finalement
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui moi me
semble absolument essentiel alors dans
ces conditions que ce soit sur l'espace
militaire et j'en terminerai la haine
que ce soit sur la question du
développement un peu de la compétitivité
et de la mise en place de nouvelles
règles se pose la question de la
coexistence quand même des acteurs dans
l'espace et des pays dans l'espace ce
surcroît d'activité jamais vu implique
un partage qui doit être repensé qui est
de plus en plus compliqué alors on vous
savez certains parlent de far-west
aujourd'hui avec des industriels qui met
un peu au pied du mur qui avance qui
éventuellement et bien développer leurs
programmes dans des interstices du droit
on ne sait pas exactement si c'est
possible et c'est en fait possible parce
que le droit ne l'a jamais vraiment
pensé c'est le cas des méga
constellation par exemple aujourd'hui
c'est méga constellation peuvent à terme
poser problème de gestion de contrôle et
de production de débris pourquoi pas
s'ils sont vraiment aussi importante
part de 12000 40000 satellite pour
certaines constatations c'est énorme
space x aujourd'hui à la menace que
c'est plus de 1600 satellite il vient
d'avoir le droit par son autorité de
régulation de déjà déplacé en orbite à
550 km plus de 4000 satellite montrent
tout ça c'est tout à fait nouveau il ya
aussi le propre des interférences par
exemple électromagnétique qui indique
est d'ailleurs les concurrents éventuels
y compris aux états unis
des lots de masques en dix ans mais à
partir du moment où le système est
installé
on va avoir beaucoup de mal à faire
coexister les fréquences à rendre nos
systèmes efficaces et ça va sans doute
nuire aux services etc
donc il ya vraiment une des
interrogations multiples dans le domaine
industriel lui-même
et puis dans le domaine des états parce
que effectivement on voit bien que
l'espace ça reste alors ne le vois pas
comme ça mais un bien commun en tout cas
quelque chose de partager et que d'une
certaine manière la sûreté des moyens
spatiaux de tous les pays c'est une
sûreté collectif par définition l'espace
est un est un milieu où tout le monde
est interdépendant avec seal un produit
un débris et bien tout le monde en
pâtira y compris celui qui l'a produit
d'ailleurs au passage
donc ça donne lieu aujourd'hui à des
discussions internationales de
régulation alors on parle par exemple un
contexte un concept existe qui s'appelle
la gestion du trafic spatiale désormais
on en vient à imaginer de gérer le
trafic spatiale c'est ce qu'on appelle
en anglais c'est connu sous le terme de
la carling est espèces traffic
management
combien ça ça implique beaucoup de
choses ça implique des réflexions sur la
conception des satellites elle-même sur
le manière de les utiliser sur la
manière de les désorbiter de gérer leur
fin de vie sur la manière de les faire
coexister entre eux sur la manière parce
qu'on y pense de plus en plus de
conduire des opérations de proximité on
appelle ça des opérations de rendez-vous
et continue t il ya des industriels qui
pensent à faire du service du service de
réapprovisionnement en carburant par
exemple ou même de réparation en orbite
tout ça implique des mouvements de
satellites
on va voir des séries de plus en plus
petit de plus en plus difficiles à
détecter et de plus en plus manoeuvrant
qui pourront faire des choses de plus en
plus élaborées donc ça c'est pareil
c'est tout à fait nouveau et ça met un
peu au pied du mur la communauté
internationale qui a besoin de gérer
collectivement ce milieu donc ça c'est
un enjeu majeur qui a effectué un psy
d'amendé conséquence de progrès en
termes de compétitivité industrielle le
pays qui édictera ou qui imposera un peu
son type de régulation est évidemment le
fera de manière à ce que et bien il en
tire éventuellement quelques profits ou
en tout cas en régulant un petit peu les
choses donc ça c'est c'est quelque chose
qui à mon sens est absolument essentiel
aujourd'hui en terme de sécurité et je
m'arrêterai là les discussions
n'avancent pas très
les grands pays sont un peu depuis pas
mal d'années bloqués arc bouté sur des
positions différentes
très rapidement et peut-être isabelle et
reviendra la chine et la russie défend
l'idée d'un traité nouveau qui
interdirait notamment le déploiement
d'armes dans l'espace
les états unis souhaitent plutôt quelque
chose de moins formel avec un code de
conduite surtout un code de bonne
conduite et plus de transparence
donc tout ça s'affrontent un peu et en
fait bloc pas mal des discussions
diplomatiques dans un contexte où
pendant ce temps des systèmes sociaux se
mettent en place
les objets se multiplient et où la
frontière entre activités civiles
activités gouvernementales civile
activités de défense activités de
sécurité est de plus en plus floue avec
un gros gros enjeu pour la france mais
on pourrait revenir la discussion c'est
d'abord d'avoir sans doute une capacité
à bien comprendre ce qui se passe dans
l'espace donc avoir des moyens de
comprendre la situation spatiale
évidemment et puis la ministre des
armées l'a dit sans doute avoir la
capacité à bien comprendre ce qui se
passe pour ses propres satellites et
éventuellement à mettre en garde contre
des contres des actions hostiles
je m'en tiendrai là parce que je sais
que j'ai peut-être dépassé déjà le temps
d'ailleurs je m'en excuse
merci merci comme je vous en prie c'est
bon voilà c'est bon donc voici donc je
vais merci de cette invitation et je
vais rapidement présenter finalement
point de vue un tout petit peu décalé en
tout cas complémentaire de celui de
xavier pasco pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord je suis géographe je ne suis pas
pour lites east comme il l'est donc je
travaille finalement peut-être plus sur
la façon dont ce milieu est occupé et je
fais plus que de la géopolitique de la
géographie politique c'est à dire que je
regarde un petit peu pour les différents
pays
du club spatiale est peut-être ce qui
ambitionne d'y entrer finalement quel
est le sens qu'on pour eux les activités
spatiales
alors j'ai souhaité sur cette première
planche de faire un petit peu des multi
facettes de ce qu'est d'activité
spatiale aujourd'hui et l'occupation
d'espagne et ce qui m'a semblé
intéressant de montrer c'est qu'en
complément de cette filiation que vous
aviez évoqué sur l'intérêt militaire du
spatial qui a généré effectivement le
développement des missiles puis des
satellites
il y a aussi ce volet d'image de
prestige et de représentation d'un état
sur la scène internationale qui
aujourd'hui jouent encore un rôle majeur
et dans la mesure où votre sujet était
assez vaste puisque vous vous intéressez
aux enjeux stratégiques globaux du
spatial j'ai jugé bon de rappeler que
effectivement la fin de cette ère
grandiose pour l'union soviétique qui
finalement d'une certaine manière
s'interrompt avec gagarine est en tout
cas est définitivement stoppée avec la
lune c'est encore important finalement
aujourd'hui dans l'image que la russie a
de son rôle comme grande puissance et du
fait que le spatial et pour elle encore
un marqueur très fort de son image
internationale
et puis derrière vous avez effectivement
ce point d'orgue extraordinaire qui est
la marche sur la lune
alors je dirais que d'une certaine façon
les états unis ne s'en sont jamais remis
de cette période de gloire il la
recherche toujours désespérément
et si vous regardez la présentation qui
est faite aujourd'hui du programme
artemis
c'est à dire ce programme de d'abord
d'une base en orbite autour de la lune
cuilhe de la possibilité d'une
installation sur la lune vous voyez
systématiquement rien évoqué cette idée
que les états unis vont pour la première
fois faire marcher alors non pas un
homme parce que ça c'est fait mais une
femme ou une personne de couleur qu'ils
vont pour la première fois développer
une activité principale et il emploie
très souvent ce terme de
programme jumelles en face à artemis
jumelles d'apollo et c'est d'ailleurs
aussi pour ça qu'ils ont choisie en
bonnes références à la mythologie le
probablement le nom d'artemis et puis en
parallèle vous avez l'arrivée de la
chine
alors cette arrivée de la chine elle
fait beaucoup parler aujourd'hui elle
fait beaucoup parler parce que je dirais
on arrive finalement à un point de
basculement de spatiale qui s'est
construit depuis mon dieu quand même
maintenant 30 ans je veux dire le
premier lancement d'un satellite chinois
c'est 1971 mais véritablement le
développement d'une industrie spatiale
chinoise et de competencia spatiale
chinoise est plus récent en réalité ce
qui se passe c'est que le spatial
chinois fonctionnent avec des plans
quinquennaux avec un horizon qui est
très claire et qui est de devenir une
des premières grandes puissances
spatiales de faire partie du club et de
faire partie du club au plus haut niveau
on évoque beaucoup nous en occident
cette idée qui provient directement des
analyses américaine de la chine comme
une menace potentielle
la chine elle met en avant et on prend à
revenir sur les analyses du phénomène le
fait qu'elle a toujours été exclus des
coopérations internationales
et de fait c'est exact de par la volonté
américaine qui considère que les
transferts de technologie spatiale
relève des technologies sensibles et
refuse absolument depuis en gros
tiananmen toute coopération avec la
chine et donc la chine
elle met en avant le fait qu'elle est
obligée qu'elle est contrainte
on est bien d'accord que c'est du disco
politique mais c'est ce qu'elle met en
avant elle est contrainte au
développement d'une autonomie spatiale
parce que sinon eh bien il se verra
interdire toute activité potentielle
future en coopération alors ça c'est le
volet politique le volet de l'image
celui qui est le mieux symbolisée par
l'exploration alors de fait c'est
évident que la présence aujourd'hui sur
mars de deux rovers seulement qui sont
leurs ovaires américain et le revers
chênois un crédit de cette idée qu'il ya
maintenant désormais de grandes
puissances
c'est un petit peu plus compliqué que ça
parce que d'abord ce que fait
persévérance le revers américain n'est
pas du tout ce que fera le revers
chinois mais il est un
baignable que la réussite chinoise en
plus lors d'une première c'est à dire on
a en gros la moitié du taux d'échec sur
marcin une mission sur deux se solde par
un échec
donc là le fait d'avoir réussi ça ça
trouve une compétence technologique
absolument remarquable
à côté de ça vous avez le volet
militaire qu évoqué tout à l'heure
xavier pasco est donc cette idée que il
faut développer des forces spatiales et
donc sur cette planche j'ai mis à la
fois la force spatiale américaine
et l'idée française qui développe pour
la première fois avec par exemple
astérix qui était un exercice
d'entraînement 7 qui m'ont dirais-je va
coller à cette image que le spatial est
un milieu qui potentiellement peut être
un lieu de un lieu d'affrontement et
qu'il faut donc s'y préparer alors qu'il
faut s'y préparer
sous l'angle de la défense active c'est
un petit peu différent de l'angle
américain sur lequel xavier parent venu
au moment des questions qui lui est
carrément du contrôle de l'espace
quand même totalement différent mais on
ne parle pas on parle pas des mêmes
entités
et puis ensuite eh bien ce que j'ai
choisi c'est de représenter c'est
finalement ces expérimentations nouvelle
qui consiste à aller par exemple
exploiter des ressources potentielles
d'un astéroïde dont qu'on a vu jusqu'à
maintenant le volet scientifique de
cette activité c'est à dire le fait que
l'europe est posée aux états sur jours
où c'était un grand succès mais les
japonais on en a on en a peu parlé ont
ramené des échantillons d'un astéroïde
l'été dernier et ça encore c'est une
grande expérience scientifique parce que
ça nous permettent de mieux comprendre
la formation des astéroïdes
mais ça devient aussi aujourd'hui dans
le contexte américain de cette
industrialisation et 2,7
commercialisation
l'idée qu'on pourrait très bien obtenir
des ressources céleste et alors c'est là
que le discours général est un petit peu
flou parce que ces ressources et l'est
si on prétend les ramener sur terre ça
n'a plus aucun intérêt
ça coûte aussi cher quasiment de faire
revenir une charge que de la queue de la
lancer en revanche l'exploitation de ses
ressources elle est allée fait pour des
bases dans l'espace donc dès lors on se
met à parler d'exploitation des
astéroïdes ou d'exploitation
de la lune on est en train de penser
activités industrielles dans l'espace et
donc d'une certaine façon présence
définitive ont franchi un autre pape
celui qu évoqué xavier avec la
multiplication du nombre de satellites
là on passe sur l'idée que l'homme
pourrait vivre et travailler dans
l'espace alors c'est un schéma qu'on
trouve déjà dans les années 80 mais qui
d'une certaine façon est aujourd'hui
plus proche d'une réalisation et pu pour
finir ça ma dernière petite plonge ses
sept représentations iconique du
lancement de par elon musk de space x
avec david bowie est la tesla qui parle
d'un truc alors il ya plusieurs façons
de voir ça donc effectivement il ya une
communication qui est quand même très
impressionnante chez space x et on sent
bien que son passé industriel et pas du
tout le passé de boeing lockheed ou
d'autres grands industriels
mais si vous voulez le fait d'envoyer
une tesla dans l'espace ça fait jamais
qu'un débris de plus donc on peut avoir
une vision beaucoup plus terre à terre
et des mystifiante or ce qui se passe
c'est que finalement le discours de
communicants de space x il est très
approprié très largement dans le monde
entier et si on revient sur les chinois
eux aussi prennent le modèle américain
dont ils prétendent se décaler mais le
prennent quand même comme horizon alors
j'essaie de passer ma planche suivante
il faut peut-être que j'active mon
système sinon je vais appeler à l'aide
on n'est pas habitué à avoir des ça y
est je ne sais pas non je suis pas je
suis pas la pire
très bientôt je si on peut passer la
planche suivante ça sera ça sera bien
voilà merci
donc je crois que c'est bon comment
c'est réussi alors les enjeux
traditionnel la conquête spatiale
un oui j'aime bien la planche suivante
les enjeux traditionnel la conquête
spatiale
il demeure et ça je pense que c'est un
point important au moment où on parle
new space
au moment où l'on parle du new space on
voit bien quand même que l'iran par
exemple qui est une puissance spatiale
depuis 2009 la corée du nord qui est une
puissance spatiale depuis 2012 la corée
du sud en 2013 met toutes en avant ses
enjeux très classique de l'image de la
souveraineté de la représentation
internationale le spatial est vraiment
un excellent vecteur et ce qui moi me
frappe c'est que vous voyez nous sommes
en 2010 par rapport à 1957
on a 50 ans d'écart et ses réflexes
fonctionne toujours et alors vraiment la
façon magnifique donc ils ont sans doute
le mieux fonctionné
c'est la mission des émirats arabes unis
autour de mars
récemment puisque finalement on a vu les
émirats arabes unis être qualifié de
puissance spatiale ce qui est quand même
pour les gens de la communauté assez
étonnant parce que une puissance
spatiale ça se définit par deux choses
le fait d'avoir son propre lanceur de le
tirer depuis son territoire ou depuis
une base que l'on contrôle et de tous
capables de fabriquer son propre
satellite les émirati ils ont contribué
ils ont monté une équipe scientifique
internationale qui a travaillé en
collaboration avec des universités
américaines
ils ont acheté un lancement sur un
lanceur japonais et ils ont lancé leurs
sondes spatiales
on n'est pas du tout sur une puissance
spatiale et cette distinction entre
puissances spatiales ou activités
spatiales
on a tendance très facilement à la
gommer et là encore il ya eu une
communication très impressionnante et
quand je lisais qui avait trois
puissances spatiales autour de mars les
etats-unis la chine et les émirats
j'avoue que je trouvais ça un petit peu
surprenant en termes de descriptions
dernier point très intéressant c'est le
développement par la chine de cette
fameuse station spatiale qui en quelque
sorte viendra après dix essais ce plan
là la chine elle a un avantage
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
durée des plans quinquennaux c'est à
dire qu'en fait en chine n'y a pas de go
and stop à l'américaine ou ailleurs
parce qu'il ya des décisions politiques
qui se prennent et que l'on change de
perspective quant à l'utilisation de
l'espace
c'est très clair c'est tout ce qui se
fait dans l'espace nous devons pouvoir
le faire alors pas forcément au même
niveau pas forcément de la même façon
sûrement pas avec les mêmes budgets mais
en tout cas il faut que nous arrivions à
être présent et à être reconnus parce
que sinon nous serons exclut tout
simplement or c'est la voie de l'avenir
et il est exclu que la chine soit à
l'extérieur de cette conquête de ce
nouveau milieu mails envoyés sur cette
planche c'est une planche qui dit la
station spatiale qui doit être terminée
en 2020 donc la chine elle aussi elle a
des délais bon alors elle va commencer
sa station en 2021
c'est absolument pas ridicule mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que on a cette
image est toujours très positive des
réalisations chinoises qui sont des
réalisations tout à fait spectaculaire
est remarquable mais qui sont des
réalisations finalement relativement
normal pour une grande puissance qui a
les moyens malgré tout de faire une
activité qui ne sera pas du tout en
termes d'importance d'ampleur et de coût
comparable à l' iss puisque là vous êtes
sur une station qui va ressembler plus à
ce que faisait des russes avec les
stations mire dans les années avant les
années 2000
or autre point important la chine a
aujourd'hui un effet une coïncidence
tout à fait favorable puisque finalement
sa station sera en fonctionnement au
moment où les ss va s'interrompre et les
plans grandioses de trump da marché sur
la lune en 2024 paraissent quand même un
petit peu compromis c'est bien que à un
moment la chine va faire ce que faisait
l'union soviétique et que nous français
nous connaissons bien
c'est à dire invité des pays tiers à
venir utiliser leur station et là
évidemment il n'y aura sans doute
pléthore de candidats donc je sais pas
si thomas pesquet appelons déjà ou pas
le chinois met de fait si vous voulez
potentiellement il faut trouver un
astronaute et quelqu'un qui a besoin de
s'entraîner et le sens de tout cet
investissement qui réalise essaient
d'acquérir de la compétence et de
l'expérience donc bien évidemment la
chine représentera un élément
intéressant
alors là c
pareil je reprends avec une image un
petit peu différente ce qui a été évoqué
la voyez ce sont les lancements qui ont
été réalisés en 2019 un petit carré
c'est un satellite quand le petit carré
est plus petit et bien c'est un petit
satellite satellite inférieure à 250 kg
voilà je crois que ça parle de soi même
à les satellites américains voyez où ils
sont satellites russes satellite
européen satellite chinois faut quand
même reconnaître qu'on a quelque chose
qui est un phénomène exceptionnel et qui
est hyper puissance spatiale américaine
or ce phénomène exceptionnel la question
pour nous européens c'est de savoir si
on le traite comme la future norme est
l'objectif ou si on le traite pour ce
qu'il est c'est-à-dire la manifestation
d'un écosystème profondément différent
du nôtre parce qu il est bien évident
que space x qui est donc à l'origine de
ce lancement de cette constellation et
de la conception de ce projet de
constellation à entre 10000 et 40000
satellite finalement il vit et il
bénéficie en termes de sûreté de son
capital de l'achat par les états unis de
ces lanceurs tour des missions
gouvernementales civils et militaires il
n'est pas le seul prestataire mais il y
a suffisamment d'argent dépensé aux
états unis pour lui permettre
d'engendrer un fonds de sécurité qui que
ce soit en bourse où que ce soit tout
simplement dans sa vie quotidienne fait
que finalement il ya la possibilité pour
lui de se lancer dans des projets
commerciaux en parallèle ce que n'ont
pas bien évidemment les heureux les
industriels européens mais aucun autre
industriel au monde
même pas les industriels chinois c'est
différent dans la mesure où on y
reviendra rapidement mais les
industriels chinois sont encore
aujourd'hui des entreprises d'état et
donc si vous voulez si vous reprenez ce
genre de plancher vous vous rendez
compte que finalement on a des modèles
complètement complètement différent en
sept planches c'est lé budget en 2019 ça
n'a pas vraiment changé
on va envoyer les états unis alors bon
je sais jamais à combien ils sont
exactement mais de toute façon mes
chiffres sont à la louche mais ils sont
suffisamment instructif avec une grosse
marge d'erreur d'autant plus que je les
ai reporter au produit national brut
pour lequel ga
peu près la même marge d'erreur y
compris par la transcription
transcription en dollars et donc vous
voyez que les états unis on va dire
mettons soit à 50 milliards vous avez à
voir l'europe qui va tourner à 12 13
milliards dont la chine n'a pas de
budget spatial officielle pour des
raisons qui tiennent à son organisation
est pas tellement au secret parce
qu'elles donnent un chiffre de budgets
de défense donc j'imagine que si elle
voulait donner un chiffre
le budget spatial elle pourrait très
bien et on aurait de toute façon
beaucoup de mal à vérifier donc la chine
ne donne pas de budget là en 2019
j'avais mis un peu inférieures au budget
européen je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est
l'équivalent du budget européen donc on
va dire 12 13 milliards de dollars la
russie elle l on le sait elle est entre
4 et 5 milliards de dollars 10 fois
moins que les états-unis le japon va
quasiment arrivés aux mêmes chiffres
budgétaires que la russie et l'inde se
situe à pas tout à fait 2 milliards de
dollars donc ce qu'on voit à travers
cette planche c'est d'abord si on le
rapporte au pnb l'importance du spatial
dans deux pays en termes
d'investissements proportionnelle c'est
à dire les états unis sont sans doute et
la russie effectivement plis investi
plus proportionnellement dans le spatial
que la chine en même temps évidemment si
j'avais fait un pnb par habitant au lieu
de prendre un pnb global vous auriez pas
eu du tout les mêmes résultats pour ceci
dit je m'en suis tenu à la norme et et
je pense que c'est intéressant comme ça
et vous voyez aussi que l'europe
ben c'est pareil elle est dans le milieu
c'est pas cet effort spatiale il
n'existe pas au niveau européen autre
point intéressant c'est qu'est ce que
ces pays arrivent à faire avec ce budget
là parce que quand même aujourd'hui
quand vous regardez le budget spatial
russe alors il faudrait rajouter la part
de location quelque sorte des soyouz
qu'ils ont beaucoup fait vivre mais vous
vous rendez compte qu'on peut finalement
faire pas mal de choses avec beaucoup
moins d'argent mais on fait pas les
mêmes choses c'est à dire qu'on fait
quelque chose de beaucoup plus rustique
c'est la voie chinoise c'est compliqué
parce que c'est un petit peu des deux
c'est à dire que c'est à la fois essayer
de ne pas tomber dans ce qu'ils
appellent la démesure des
investissements américains mais c'est en
même temps pas faire des choses un peu
rustique et dépassé comme le fait la
russie parce que tout simplement elle à
l'héritage de son outil industriel de
l'époque soviétique
mais c'est au contraire faire quelque
chose de très moderne puisque la chine
se projette
sur les exploitations spatiale du futur
alors je reviens sur l'interaction dans
l'espace donc d'avis évoqué des chiffres
de 2020 donc ça c'est quelque chose que
qu'il ne fait que s'accroître l'écart
entre les états unis et le reste du
monde est tout à fait marquant et cette
planche là puisqu'on parlait de défis
stratégiques
je les prises même si elle est un petit
peu anciennes parce qu'elle montre
finalement en quelque sorte la
préférence nationale
c'est à dire que si vous regardez
l'union soviétique -puis la russie- j'ai
cumulé tous les satellites lancés depuis
vous voyez que finalement tous les
satellites russes ont été lancés en
russie c'est à dire que là vous avez une
mono activité spatiale purement
nationales en revanche aux états unis
vous faites lancé certains nouveaux
satellites ce sont les différentes
couleurs qui correspondent aux pays de
lancement dont vous voyez qu aux
etats-unis à des satellites qui sont
lancés par la russie par l'europe
éventuellement à une époque les punks
iridium par la chine mais si vous
regardez l'europe qui aimons en quarts
en milieu là finalement vous vous rendez
compte que la défense d'un lanceur
européen et l'utilisation exclusive d'un
lanceur européen pendant la période donc
jeudi jusqu'en 2015 elle est déjà assez
assez éloquente et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est qu'aujourd'hui
finalement ce qu'on voit c'est avec le
développement des petits lanceurs là
encore des démarches nationale qui vont
faire que tout compte fait il n'ya pas
comme aux états unis en particulier une
conjonction de tous les besoins sur les
mêmes types de lanceurs
en gros il ya toujours dans le monde
deux prestataires de lanceurs personne
ne prend le risque de n'avoir qu'un
prestataire parce que on imaginerait
bien ce qui se passerait si ce
prestataire était retenu au sol par par
des difficultés techniques mais en tout
cas en europe ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
avec l'apparition et la multiplication
des petits lanceurs c'est que là encore
on va avoir des fragmentations nationale
et d'une certaine façon cela tient au
fait que le spatial
il est toujours quand même couplée à des
enjeux nationaux et c'est à vous que je
vais expliquer ça mais la grande
faiblesse de l'europe c'est précisément
cette absence d'intégration d'un
d'enjeux nationaux qui deviendrait un
enjeu
hop et r et ça on sait pas le faire dans
le milieu spatial c'est très important
aussi aujourd'hui en particulier pour un
autre point xavier évoqué la question de
la gestion du trafic et de la place que
l'europe pourrait prendre pour définir
ces réglementations futures du trafic
spatiale qui vont être assez
intéressante parce qu imaginer qu'on
impose un certain nombre de satellites
par opérateur voyez bien l'impact que
cela pourrait avoir sur quelqu'un comme
elon musk enfin il ya vraiment derrière
des gros enjeux mais il ya un deuxième
enjeu très important qui est celui de la
surveillance spatiale et la surveillance
spatiale c'est être capable d'identifier
tous les satellites moment précis en
sachant quelle est la nationalité du
satellite c'est à dire effectivement de
connaître le satellite or on va en
reparler très vite quand je vais
atteindre la planche à la militarisation
la question aujourd'hui c'est que seuls
les états unis dans une moindre mesure
la russie sont capables de savoir très
précisément à qui appartiennent les
différents satellites et quels sont leur
biographie
si on imagine aujourd'hui que les états
unis qui ont tendance à considérer que
les frappes préventives ça fait partie
d'un arsenal internationales acceptables
ce dont on peut avoir quelques sur
lequel on peut avoir quelques doutes
si un jour je fais de la science fiction
mais si un jour les etats unis décidé de
s'attaquer aux satellites chinois au
motif que ce satellite chinois les
menaces et nous nous sommes totalement
dans l'incapacité de dire en temps réel
parce que nous avons quand même quelques
capacités en particulier en france nous
serions dans l'incapacité de dire en
temps réel si effectivement il y avait
une menace potentielle parce que nous
n'avons pas cette capacité et moi je
suis très surprise que ce programme de
surveillance spatiale qui aujourd'hui
porté par l'union européenne et qui
avancent lentement
finalement c'est pas des programmes les
plus coûteux parmi les programmes
spatiaux et de très loin
je pense que la première fois que nous
en avons parlé à xavier parce que nous
étions tous jeunes et c'était justement
au ministère de la défense à l'époque et
tout le monde trouvait que c'était
relativement farfelue puisque les
américains nous fournissent les données
sauf que au bout d'un moment ça devient
un problème et on voit bien aujourd'hui
les américains proposent et même des
services privés d'associations et là on
a un enjeu stratégique majeur
sur lequel on ne peut que s'étonner
finalement qui est pas plus pas plus
d'efforts européen alors les puissances
spatiales
c'est les forces en présence et là
encore je suis très frappé par
l'importance qu'on accorde tous à la
vulgate américaine tout compte fait
parce que les chinois vont marcher sur
la lune
ce dessin amusant bondues chinois qui
arrivent sur la lune pour aller casser
le drapeau américain
c'est quand même une façon de voir les
choses qui revient à être extrêmement
exclusive parce que finalement pourquoi
les chinois ne se poserait t-il pas sur
la lune et pourquoi dans la logique du
programme spatial chinois
il n'y aurait pas besoin d'aller sur la
lune et je ne nie nullement au contraire
que c'est bien dans l'idée d'une
d'augmentation des capacités chinoises
c'est très clair je veux dire les
chinois veulent être parmi les premiers
dans l'espace là dessus y'a pas de
questions maintenant systématiquement
représenter ça comme une menace créée
risque de créer un genre de prophétie
auto réalisatrice
et de fait aujourd'hui je suis très
frappé de voir en plus avec xi jinping
qui a un discours très nationaliste
exacerbé combien les chinois
instrumentalise très habilement cette
représentation de leurs compétences dans
l'espace faites par les journaux
américains n'y a pas besoin de faire de
la propagande les américains eux mêmes
écrivent la suprématie américaine est
menacé aujourd'hui par la chine pour ce
parfait et ça je pense que c'est un vrai
problème ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'il
ne faut pas prendre en compte la réalité
de la compétition spatiale et le risque
que représentent les chinois et je pense
qu'il ya sans doute pour nous européens
peut être un discours autonome à à
trouver sans être naïf bien bien
évidemment et sans forcément tomber dans
la dénonciation de l'autre comme les
états unis le font aussi un peu par
réflexe parce que c'est ce qu'ils ont
toujours fait à l'époque de la guerre
froide avec l'union soviétique et parce
que aussi bien sûr sur le plan
commercial il ya cette compétition très
très dur entre les etats-unis et la
chine alors la politique spatiale
chinoise en quelques mots un se sont
et priorités nationales qui font une
place nouvelle au spatial militaire sage
insiste la chine a eu d'abord besoin du
spatial pour le volet infrastructures
qu'évoquer xavier parce que tout
simplement nous en europe nous avons
l'habitude d'avoir des infrastructures
terrestres et en nappant chine si vous
voulez gérer le territoire si vous
voulez faire des télécommunications et
bien vous passez par les satellites
c'est un investissement unique qui
durent très longtemps et qui vous permet
de desservir la totalité de votre
territoire
ensuite l'armée chinoise se modernise et
donc elle intègre le spatial ils sont
très bien compris la leçon de la guerre
du golfe
et effectivement on a vu depuis 2000
15,1 spatiales militaires s'autonomiser
au sein du spatial chinois qui n'est pas
vraiment à mon sens dirigé par les
militaires mais qui est dirigé par
évidemment les instances politiques
chinoises qui elle-même intègre
systématiquement l'outil militaire et
vous avez une forme de commission mais
taro industriel enfin qui est la castine
la commission militaire centrale
et cette commission militaire centrale
finalement elle intègre forcément enjeux
civile enjeux militaires
d'où cette idée de la dualité de
l'intégration civilo militaire et qu'il
présente dans ce sens là ce qui me
paraît relativement logique mais qui
font que les capacités spatiales
militaires chinoises vont monter en
puissance très très rapidement alors ils
ont même créé une quatrième armée etc
etc
ceci dit ce qui met en avant c'est des
capacités essentiellement défensive bon
c'est sûr que vu leur situation ça
paraît cohérent et que pour eux la
course aux armements dans l'espace
elle est peu bénéfique elle l'est
d'autant moins que finalement
aujourd'hui empêcher le développement
d'armes dans l'espace c'est pénaliser
les états unis sens pénalisés soit même
puisqu'ils n'ont pas cette vulnérabilité
que les états unis ont sur leur outil
militaire c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
la russie a exactement la même position
donc là j'ai choisi de montrer un autre
type d'enjeux stratégiques du spatial
qui est finalement la diplomatie
spatiale que je présentais récemment aux
à la commission des affaires étrangères
c'est que finalement si vous regardez
aujourd'hui la chine avec qui elle
coopère et comment elle développe ses
coopérations vous voyez bien que dans ce
domaine là comme dans beaucoup d'autres
elle met un certain nombre de dix donc
jusqu'où ça ira
c'est difficile à dire mais en tout cas
elle pose le pied elle s'installe elle
se fait reconnaître et elle le fait sur
en fait pas du tout sur un plan
commercial mais sur un plan soit de
trucks toit de stratégie d' influence
elle peut d'autant mieux le faire et le
faire avec qui elle veut que comme elle
est exclue de toute technologie
américaine eh bien elle n'est tenu par
aucun type de réglementation sur les
transferts et donc autant nous européens
parfois une peut nous arriver d'être
pénalisé quand on veut lancer ou
fabriquer un satellite pour des pays
tiers qui ne sont pas approuvées par les
états unis lors des transferts de
technologie autant la chine est une
alternative mondiales et internationales
ce qui en termes de sécurité post amm en
face à mon avis un sérieux problème
alors je vais passer très vite sur la
russie bon le spatial russe en recherche
d'un d'un projet politique je crois que
finalement c'est ça la vraie la vraie
question c'est autant la chine c'est
pourquoi elle veut être une très grande
puissance spatiale autant la russie a
plus de mal la russie elle est là un
outil spatiales militaires qu'elle a
développé pendant la guerre froide
qu'elle continue plus ou moins
entretenir
ça va quand même ça inclut la navigation
puisque gps ou glonass sont à l'origine
des outils militaires pour ces deux
grandes puissances
elle essaie donc et donc elle se sert de
ce spatiales militaires pour se faire
reconnaître sur la scène internationale
face à une compétition chinoise
c'est pas une compétition directe
puisque en plus on voit aujourd'hui une
synergie officielle entre les russes et
les chinois est en tout cas en terme
d'image la russie aujourd'hui se trouve
je dirais est mise dans une position de
faiblesse puisqu'on parle que d'elle
alors qu'on parle de plus en plus de la
chine et que de fait la chine réalise
des choses que la russie bien incapable
de réaliser
bon on a raté la fenêtre
d'exploration mars dans une mission qui
était européens et russes et un petit
peu de la faute de tout le monde non je
vous demande si on peut raccourcir parce
que j'ai beaucoup de qu'une dizaine de
onze questions je vais me passer de me
donner deux minutes je finis donc du
coup le problème de la russie
aujourd'hui et c'est aussi pour ça sans
doute qu'elle développe les les
comment dirais-je les démonstrations
offensives dans l'espace et qu'on parle
beaucoup beaucoup d'elle par exemple sur
les armes potentiellement enfin les
actions militaires potentiellement
hostile dans l'espace alors je ne vais
pas du coup évoqué la russie ce j'avais
fait notre planche sur un diplomate y
spécial de la russie dont on peut voir
qu'elle est aujourd'hui un petit peu
mise à mal aussi par la chine et je
voulais terminer sur l'espace indien
puisqu'on parle des enjeux stratégiques
puisque les indiens aujourd'hui qu'ils
étaient partis de programmes
internationaux civils ouvert à l'onu en
finissent aujourd'hui avec arme à plomb
cuba s'est pas du tout le tir
antisatellites que premier ministre mais
audi a autorisé en 2010 9 sél annonce
qu'il va y avoir le lancement d'un homme
dans l'espace qui est tout à fait
contraire à ce qui a été toute la
philosophie du spatial indien
donc la question aujourd'hui c'est
l'espace futur champ de bataille
moi je pense que ça ça mérite quand même
un point d'interrogation certes l'espace
est un milieu qui va devenir de plus en
plus convoité qui est de plus en plus
convoité dans lequel un état comme les
états unis à des enjeux de sécurité
nationaux qui sont absolument
essentielles qui devient important pour
tous les pays puisque tous les pays
développent aussi une activité spatial
civil et militaire
la question est est ce que la guerre
dans le milieu spatial ça ressemble à la
gare ailleurs et qu elle est finalement
le bénéfice au total de faire la guerre
dans l'espace ou est-ce qu'il ya pas des
moyens de faire autrement
et donc ça voilà je terminais et donc
voilà ça sera ma dernière planche
la question du spatial militaire et de
son devenir
donc là c'est pareil les satellites
militaires opérationnelles en 2000
je vois pas ma planche de loin 6 et 2020
donc vous voyez la masse des satellites
militaires américains et puis surtout
vous voyez que les types d'activités
sont différentes puisque en rouge vous
avez l'observation de la terre là où
finalement vous avez en bleu les
télécoms et surtout surtout surtout en
violet vous avez les programmes
technologiques et là vous voyez que les
états unis ont quand même vraiment
encore une énorme une énorme longueur
dames ans donc voilà c'est ma dernière
planche vont penser la géopolitique de
l'espace est pas tout à fait votre sujet
mais c'est quand même me semble-t-il
aussi un sujet un sujet important
merci et désolé cg excédés merci madame
ça vole c'est passionnant on vous sent
passionné mais heureusement le temps
nous est un peu content et je vais
commencer donc par donne la parole à
olivier cigolotti qu'étant
visioconférence si nous en tant
religieuse que tu nous entends mon temps
on n'entend pas très bien si tu peux
parler peut-être plus près du micro je
ne sais pas une question peut-être plus
pour monsieur pascoe qui a évoqué dans
sa conclusion les éléments liés à la
régulation
monsieur parce que vous avez
effectivement après que l'espace est un
colin partager sans frontières
aujourd'hui serait inconcevable d'avoir
de ne pas avoir de régulation au niveau
de la circulation aérienne et pourtant
vous avez également rappelé la
multiplication des élancements grappes
de petits satellites et de nano
satellites certains étant à la fois
incontrôlée et indétectables ces
derniers risquent de provoquer de plus
en plus d'incidents avec des satellites
plus opérationnelle de grande taille
j'en veux pour preuve l'exemple en
septembre 2019 de stareo que de space x
est d'ailleurs luce de l'ess a selon
vous monsieur pas secours tels outils de
régulation internationale sont
envisageables et quelle instance
au cur yale éventuellement seraient en
capacité d'en assurer le respect de la
mise en oeuvre et surtout est-il
concevable qu'en vous de d'assurer une
régulation spatial civil et spatiales
militaires
je vous remercie je fais une série de
deux séries de cinq rames de cinq
questions enfin une série de cinq une
série de six comme ça ça te permettra
peut-être d'être plus d'être plus rapide
le suivant c'est pascal allizard ce qui
est très le président merci merci à vous
deux pour votre présentation avec quatre
collègues de la commission nous
travaillons sur un rapport sur la
puissance chinoise en europe et
notamment sur ce volet spatiale et on
s'interroge notamment sur la profondeur
de l'accord de la relation sur ce sujet
entre la chine et la russie alors vous
nous avez présenté la chine
c'est un peu vite sur la russie c'est
normal le président on vous avait
demandé d'accélérer et je ne veux pas
contrarier le président mais j'aimerais
bien voilà tout à fait c'est l'occasion
d'en parler si vous pouvez comme
détaillé un petit peu la vision sur la
russie et et nous préciser la nature de
la relation entre les deux il nous
semble nous que la russie quand même
encore un avantage technologique et que
la vente de cet avantage fait partie de
l'accord ou de la recherche d'accords
merci je me doutais bien pascal qu'on
allait revenir sur le sujet de la russie
gisèle jourda fille alors c'est pas du
tout ce n'est donc pas du tout donc
concerté mais c'était exactement le lien
que je souhaitais donc que vous
apprendrez que vous approfondie sied
madame parce que d'après donc
un de vos responsables de l'ifri moscou
pourrait se servir justement de d'une
main tendue de la chine pour pouvoir
justement donc dans dans cette alliance
pour le spatial qu'ils ont conclus qui
finalement comment l accord gagnant
gagnant entre qui et qui
et finalement quand on voit comment
cette question est prégnante
comment vouliez vous voyez vous cette
redistribution des cartes voyez nos
questions sont vraiment similaires
ensuite j'en aurai une seconde pour vous
monsieur parce que j'ai été très
intéressé quand vous avez évoqué la
gestion la gestion du trafic spatiale
donc est-ce que comment cela se dessine
est il merci beaucoup merci gilles andré
gattolin voyez merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse plutôt à
madame soussou sur baysse verger vous
avez montré et je trouve avec vous
l'avez très bien illustré la part qui a
de symbolique de travail de l'imaginaire
humain
finalement toujours tout le monde a
toujours rêvé à l'espace moyens un
aspect un peu génériques alors la
question peut peut-être paraître
farfelue mais la manière dont on appelle
les voyageurs de l'espace varie
maintenant avec pratiquement chaque
nation on à l'astronaute cosmonautes
dans les années 60 une blague russe
disaient les américains sont partis dans
les étoiles pour trouver dieu
et dire qu'ils les américains nous nous
allons dans le cosmos pour montrer que
le cosmos et rationnelle et que dieu
n'existe pas alors on a maintenant le
taïkonautes qui renvoie comme le
spationaute au terme d' espaces on a le
vieux-mans hôtes indiens qui lui renvoie
au ciel avec une dimension plus
spirituelle je trouve quand même assez
évocateur que pour qualifier la même
chose un voyageur de l'espace y compris
dans chacune des langues
on est une traduction ce qui montre bien
qu'on a une part si élise le pas c'est
lisa sion de l'espace et risque-t-on
d'avoir de voir émerger d'autres noms
pour qualifier chaque
petits terriens keira faire un tour dans
l'espace merci andré pour terminer cette
série de questions jean-marc déchaînés
oui merci monsieur le président moi ma
question rejoint totalement celle
d'olivier cigolotti sait jusqu'où
pourront noyer dont sept dans cet espace
avec l'arrivée massive depuis l'année
2000 l'institution privée de de la potée
des agences état d au déroulé de tir
groupé plusieurs états comme en europe
en assiste là avec les projets vous les
avez cités ils ont été cités le projet
star ding on peut le comparer finalement
1 8 6 internationale qui arrosera tout
le monde
une connexion ou ici planétaire sans fil
tout cela va poser des problèmes
d'autres agences d'autres structures de
télécommunications sont aussi présentes
je ne parle pas du deuxième des origines
qui a lui aussi un projet de plus de
3000 satellites dans l'espace au nuevo
si on va assister à aux intérêts de
samsung de telesat et d'autres qui vont
faire que des dizaines de milliers de
satellites ont ce retour et dans
l'espace peut-on continuer avec cette
seule institution qui est l'union
internationale des télécommunications
qui souvent finalement les intérêts
privés ou aux nationaux ne sollicite
même plus ne lui prenne même plus pour
des problèmes de confidentialité et
expédie dans l'espace des satellites
peut-on continuer en clair il ya le
problème de la pollution et des briques
on ne peut pas récupérer qui vont
arriver et qu'elle les outils sont
aujourd'hui à la disposition des états
on a une loi en france spatiale mais là
on n'a rien en commun et on est dans un
vide juridique assez important je crois
que votre approche des problèmes de
défense et de la soupe comme un cycle
venir pour le moment américaine en
matière de défense on a là aussi une
guerre économique qui va arriver
et à quel moment pour attend une nation
pourra-t-elle considérer qu'elle est
agressé fils alban ne serait-ce le
commercialement ce qu'il y a des règles
dont l'âge mental a défini à définir ou
pas et est ce qu'une nation pourra
simplement considéré légitime manque
hélas dans son intérêt de faire usage de
la force et on sait bien que les en
matière militaire en tout cas la force
le dernier recours ça sera quand même la
tacc des stations terrestres mais là ça
provoquerait un nom clonage pas croyable
dans le quel est vôtre vous quelles sont
vos pistes de réflexion sur cette
régulation qui est indispensable de plus
le 20e siècle on est depuis l'arrivée
d'un tir est incroyable sur sept et ce
dans l'espace merci merci jean marc
monsieur directeur même je vous laisse
gérer peut-être entre vous le les
réponses très bien je vais traiter
effectivement les questions se recoupent
mais et tourne autour des de ces
questions de régulation alors
effectivement de kehl aujourd'hui quel
forum se prête à ce genre de rien et
sans remords qu'est-ce qu'on veut
réguler bon finalement quand on parle de
gestion du trafic spatiale c'est en
référence à plusieurs choses c'est en
référence effectivement à cette
émergence des méga constellation vous
n'avez pas cité un projet nouveau qui
vient d'apparaître avec un ce qu'on
appelle starnes est semble-t-il le dépôt
par la chine d'un dossier auprès de
limiter pour 13000 satellite de
télécommunications qui vient s'ajouter
d'une certaine manière à tous les
projets que vous avez cités donc on voit
bien qu effectivement tous ces
satellites étant placés sur des orbites
basses on a sans doute
alors même si aujourd'hui l'espace
aérien est grand et évident on a une
densification les américains appellent
salle l'espace congestionné et c est la
difficulté aujourd'hui on a plusieurs
forums où ces choses se discute alors au
niveau des nations unies c'est ce qu'on
appelle le comité des utilisations
pacifiques de l'espace extra
atmosphérique qui essayent de d'établir
en ce moment c'est son grand projet des
mesures de développement durable des
activités spatiales ce qu'on appelle les
longues turn sustainability donc les lts
et les pays se sont accordés sur un
certain nombre de grands principes mais
évidemment dès que ces principes rentre
un peu dans le détail bien les
discussions s'arrêtent au jeu
lui et donc nations-unies sont un forum
nécessaire parce que c'est de le forum
qui permette d'universaliser les
discussions mais cet affront qui n'est
pas suffisant parce que eh bien les
discussions de détails se font ailleurs
alors elles se font aujourd'hui dans
différents cadres elles se font pour ce
qui concerne les interférences par
exemple globalement le trafic de la main
le contrôle du trafic se passer à la
gestion de trafic spatiale sa porte sur
quoi ça porte sur les débris sa porte
sur ses opérations de rendez vous ils
vont être de plus en plus fréquentes
comment va organiser gérer rendre
transparents ces opérations qui consiste
à rapprocher un satellite d'un autre
éventuellement d'y intervenir
et puis ça concerne aussi les
interférences entre les systèmes le fait
que le système se brouillent rond alors
ces différents points sont traités dans
des instances différentes vous avez
évoqué lé 8 et effectivement lu 8 et
aujourd'hui c'est un peu une chambre
d'enregistrement de projets nationaux
dont l'autorisation est donnée par
l'autorité de régulation nationales
c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment où en
tant qu'industriel vous avez une
autorisation de la part de votre
autorité
la licence en quelque sorte et bien vous
déposez vos femmes immigrées les
dossiers auprès de lui tu es et l'unité
juste s'assure que votre système ne va
pas de manière explicite physique
empêcher un autre système de fonctionner
alors aujourd'hui on est dans un dans
une dans une logique où ces méga
constellation ne sont pas vus comme
explicitement empêchant de fonctionner
d'autres systèmes
mais là c'est là où on touche et on voit
bien qu'on va devoir réguler c'est là on
touche la limite de la prospective on se
rend bien compte et les industriels eux
mêmes le disent maintenant la
coexistence la multiplication de ces
différents systèmes et volant à peu près
sur les mêmes orbite sur des fréquences
très voisines vont prendre de plus en
plus compliqué le bon fonctionnement et
in fine et le bon fonctionnement et la
strate une infrastructure terrestre qui
en dépendent et c'est le bon
fonctionnement des satellites
géostationnaires donc là les gens
commencent on voit ça depuis quelques
mois ce thème commence à monter comme
étant un thème un thème important
alors pour ce qui concerne les débris
par exemple on a aujourd'hui bien une
régulation très très j'allais dire un
gentleman agreement entre différentes
agences spatiales dans le cadre du comme
de la commission
interagences gestion des débris l'iadc
qui dit mais voilà si vous êtes
quelqu'un de raisonnable vous devez par
exemple après la fin de vie de votre
satellites en orbite basse le désorbiter
le détruire l'atmosphère au bout de 25
ans dans l'espace de 25 ans quand vous
exploitez un satellite géostationnaire
et qu'il arrête en fin de vie vous devez
être capable de garder suffisamment de
carburant pour le propulser en orbite
plus haute pour le finalement le
neutraliser le mettre sur une orbite
parking une orbite cimetière
ça ce sont des recommandations ce ne
sont pas des traits ne sont pas des
obligations est donc le stm aujourd'hui
ce qu'on appelle le space traffic
management et bien effectivement c'est
devenu un peu un objet de deux j'allais
dire possible de confrontation des
intérêts et que ce soit pour les
opérations de proximité avec par exemple
ça va être par exemple des exigences
techniques on va finir par édicter des
règles qui exigeront un certain niveau
de performance
on sent bien content évidemment
qu'immédiatement selon les niveaux de
performance que vous allez exigé vous
allez créer des distorsions de
compétitivité etc alors même que bon
tout ça doit se discuter
l'europe aujourd'hui s'en saisit sans
saisir en lançant différents projets
d'études
il se trouve que la fondation pour la
recherche stratégique dirigeants de ces
projets aujourd'hui coordonne ces
projets européen d'études dérégulation
alors avec à la fois un volet
technologique quels sont les manques
technologique dans l'europe pourrait
souffrir par exemple dans le domaine de
l'observation de l'espace de la
situation spatiale comme le disait ma
collègue isabelle ou qu'elles sont et
bien les problèmes de normes juridiques
des problèmes politiques induits et
éventuellement l'analyse des
conséquences économiques en matière
industrielle compétitivité donc tout ça
fait l'objet j'allais dire d'études
naissante simplement aux états unis on
commence à voir une très très grosse
réflexion sur je dirais la
l'internationalisation des règles qu'on
veut s'imposer à soi même et donc on est
effectivement là j'entre dans un jeu
normatif très fort alors pour ce qui est
de je dirais 2
la place des acteurs privés dans le
futur alors là évidemment on est
aujourd'hui on manque d'une gestion
collective d'une gestion internationale
j'allais dire d'une gestion raisonnable
du développement c'est une grand projet
privé et vous avez évoqué une sorte de
vide juridique oui effectivement
aujourd'hui un pays en fonction de la
loi spéciale qu'il s'impose à lui même
peut donner le droit à son industrie de
conduire son activité industrie dans
l'espace au passage ça s'est passé par
exemple pour en novembre 2015 avec le
vote de la loi aux états unis de
l'autorisation pour les entreprises
privées d'exploiter les ressources extra
terrestre ce vote en réalité a été très
discutée au niveau international parce
que on se demande jusqu'à quel point les
juristes en tout cas se demande jusqu'à
quel point ça ne contrevenait pas aux
termes du traité de 1967 d'utilisation
de l'espace extra atmosphérique qui
consacre comme un principe le principe
de non appropriation comme un principe
cardinal des droit international
aujourd'hui je dirais on n'est pas tout
à fait sortis de ce débat en réalité un
certain nombre de jurys s'accordent pour
dire que exploités ne veut pas dire
s'approprier bon on est on est dans la
main de l'argutie juridique mais on voit
bien qu'il ya une poussée une très forte
tension très forte pression des grandes
puissances spatiales et en partie de la
puissance américaine c'est vrai mais on
voit bien qu'il ya d'autres intérêts en
dehors des états unis qui de toute façon
font évoluer la réflexion juridique tu
es là c'est vraiment pour l'europe
on est à la croisée des chemins ce à
dire qu'il faut savoir se situer dans ce
dans ce dans ce débat à savoir faire
valoir ses compétences faire valoir ses
intérêts et et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
que ce soit en matière de d'occupation
de l'espace circumterrestre orbite basse
géostationnaire ou éventuellement en
matière d'exploration humaine du système
solaire et de la logistique qu'on y
déploiera et des activités industrielles
qui éventuellement n'exercerait même si
on peut avoir beaucoup de effectivement
de doute sur la logique économique de
tout ça là il faut que l'europe ait
effectivement s'arme pour qu'elle
défende ses intérêts on a des intérêts à
faire valoir on a des compétences de
premier rang mondial
et là pour le coup on a un intérêt et
donc il faut en prendre conscience et
une prise de conscience collective
donc je vais partir sur un registre un
peu différent si vous permettez je
compte je retiens et puis je mettre un
peu plus de temps sur la russie et la
chine qui me paraît un sujet très
important
oui bien sûr on donne des noms
différents est alarmant il ya deux
choses qui me frappe c'est que quand
même on impose un petit peu à tout le
monde de cette racine grecque de notes
donc
et si là c'est ça le navigateur et ce
qui est très intéressant c'est que du
coup les chinois ils ont deux noms c'est
à dire qu'ils ont taïkonautes qu'on
connaît bien et taxer le milieu donc ils
ont reconstruit une appellation à usage
en anglais international
et puis ils ont leurs mots à eux qui
veut dire aussi navigateur de l'espace
mais en chinois et kiên giang one que je
prononce extrêmement mal et je pense que
c'est pour s'éviter ce genre de
difficultés et d'incompréhension que
finalement ils ont choisi de se caler
sur ce modèle international donc c'est
intéressant parce que là on mesure quand
même culturellement le poids que peut
avoir
l'histoire des premières puissances
spatiales alors oui des indiens ils ont
leur propre nom ils sont en train de le
mettre en lumière puisque c'est
exactement puisque ça devient nouveau
comme idée et ce qui me frappe moi
surtout c'est que vous n'avez pas de nom
japonais vous n'avez pas de noms
européens et les européens à
l'initiative de la france ont tenté le
spationaute au milieu des années 1980
émouvant bonne française je pensais que
c'était adopté est en fait pas du tout à
l'aise à ce sont des astronautes des
tomates pesquet est un astronaute et pas
un spationaute et donc c'est assez
amusant de constater que seule la france
avait finalement à coeur de porter cette
singularité
encore une fois entre les états unis et
l'union soviétique et à une époque
vous aviez même une forme de d'adhésion
qui fait que par exemple je crois que
jean pierre haigneré qui a volé à bord
de vaisseaux russes lui s'appelait
cosmonaute est ce que pour lui ils
étaient formés sur les cosmonautes donc
moi ce que je retiendrai tout ça c'est
que ben oui quid de l'europe là dedans
et les mêmes problèmes pour le japon
parce que nous n'avons pas de moyens
autonomes et puis derrière quel nom va
donner aux touristes de l'espace ça
j'avoue que je suis assez intéressé de
voir de voir ce qu'il va être inventé
sa lettre est drôle donc bon ça c'est
c'est eh voilà la partie la partie
complique
aujourd'hui les liens entre la chine et
la russie dans l'espace alors si c'est
mon truc remarque je serais remonté
apparemment il a peut-être été coupée
sur la pop
en tout cas si voilà c'est bon c'est bon
c'est juste qu'il lui faut un petit
temps de un petit temps de réaction si
on remonte par exemple sur hors jeu
peut-être remonter sur sur la chine bon
je sais pas quand vous regardez par
exemple au sujet qui est la diplomatie
spatiale de la russie et de la chine
la diplomatie spatiale de la russie et
la diplomatie spatial de la chine il ya
des endroits où malgré tout elles sont
un tout petit peu en concurrence par
exemple l'egypte si vous regardez alors
il faudrait toujours mans dans l'autre
sens
alors je n'avais pas prévu de faire
cette comparaison mais si vous arrivez à
mémoriser un petit peu de toute façon je
laisserai mes planches
vous vous rendez compte que ce soit en
amérique latine où que ce soit au moyen
orient
et bien finalement russie et chine
apparaissent comme des alternatives un
certain nombre de pays donc là ça va
être quelque chose qu'il faudra quand
même un moment ou un autre
gérer mais cette coopération entre la
russie et la chine
elle est très ancienne roskosmos alors
elle est très ancienne on va pas
remonter aux années 60 et à la rupture
bon entre le bloc soviétique etc mais
depuis la fin de l'union soviétique
la chine a fait partie des pays qui se
sont intéressés à la récupération des
capacités existantes et le programme
spatial habité chinois vient directement
de la coopération qui a été initiée en
même si la chine a à coeur de se
réapproprier le programme et de le
développer par elle-même puisque en fait
elle a mis plus de dix ans entre 91 et
2003 pour faire son propre vaisseau avec
son propre lanceur et son propre et son
propre module donc en fait ce qui est
intéressant c'est que finalement vous
avez une agence force cosmos une seule
dans le monde qui est en chine qui est à
pékin dont vous avez cette ancienne td
lien vous avez une université la grande
université technologique
chinoise en domaine spatial c'est
l'université de harbin harbin on
enseigner en russe à une époque et vous
aviez des enseignants russe et vous avez
encore beaucoup de gens dont on va dire
d'une cinquantaine d'années qui parle
russe dans le spatial chinois
c'est intéressant de voir à l'ietf des
chinois parlait en russe avec des russes
donc ça vous avez cette très ancienne
coopération ayant pesé mine avait été
formé en russie aussi et c'est donc donc
il ya ce substrat il ya un deuxième
élément qui leur est commun c'est
finalement le fait qu'aujourd'hui
eh bien ils se sentent à l'écart du
monde occidental et ils se sentent de
plus en plus à l'écart et on voit bien
les difficultés de la russie aujourd'hui
face à une politique des sanctions un
des sanctions qui est quand même la
pénalise beaucoup et entre autres dans
le domaine spatial
parce qu'elle n'a pas par rapport à la
chine cette autonomie dans dans le
domaine de l'électronique et cette
capacité finalement en termes de
composants ni d'innovation donc est ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui on a deux acteurs
qui ont finalement un intérêt bien
compris au moins apparent à nous et
leurs compétences c'est à dire qu' il ya
des avances technologiques dans le
domaine du spatial militaire des russes
qui sont encore très nette par rapport
aux chinois je prendrai un exemple celle
alerte avancée c'est à dire la capacité
de satellites a détecté des tirs de
missiles aujourd'hui la russie a signé
un accord de coopération avec la chine
sur ce sujet jusqu'où la russie va être
prête à ac/dc dernière brique de
compétences supérieures à la chine
ça c'est quand même à discuter c'est pas
du tout évidente
pardon et puis du côté chinois lié à
l'idée qu'on voudrait bien quand même
s'émanciper et pas avoir l'air d'être en
train de copier ce que font les russes
et de dépendre des russes donc tout
compte fait il ya à la fois un intérêt
mutuel bien compris et d'ailleurs si
vous regardez la déclaration qui a été
faite d'une station lunaire russo
chinoise elle a été faite d'abord par
les russes parce que là vous êtes un
déficit de progrès de vous est en
déficit de projets russes là où vous
avez un projet chinois il ya que les
chinois ont toujours dit qu'ils
voulaient aller sur la lune ils n'y sont
jamais allés les rues si son talent et
ils ont ramené des échantillons ils ont
pas envoyé des hommes mais ils ont
ramené des échantillons est donc
finalement les chinois eux ont pas
véritablement besoin des russes pour
maintenir leurs programmes là où les
russes ont besoin de trouver un allié or
l'allié traditionnel qui étaient les
états unis avec les ss devient
aujourd'hui un ali qui est beaucoup
moins attractif en particulier parce que
bien la russie serait traité en junior
partner de fait parce qu'elle n'a pas
les compétences et parce que maintenant
les états unis n'ont plus besoin de la
russie alors que dans les ss la russie
était quand même
l'origine du projet est au coeur du
projet donc cette dimension là elle fait
que la russie cherche à à réapparaître
dans de la coopération parce qu'elle
n'est pas prête à le faire tout seul
la chine crédibilise son image d'
alternative en s'associant à la russie
en s'adossant à la russie est
effectivement pour nous européens ça
pose un problème réel c'est à dire que
finalement jusqu'où vont-ils être
capable d'agréger autour de ce noyau
d'autres puissances
est ce qu'ils sont une alternative
finalement et c'est leur ambition au
projet américain
alors vous avez un grand cas c'est celui
de l'inde sauf que l'inde et la chine
ça se passe pas très bien mais malgré
tout dans certains domaines l'inde elle
est quand même prête à aller se
positionner là où elle retirera le plus
davantage et il est probable que l'inde
jouera un petit peu le jeu qu'elle a
toujours joué c'est à dire essayer de
bénéficier d'un côté non alignés en
fonction des avantages mutuels et la
coopération de la russie avec l'inde
elle est très ancien et elle est très
forte même si elle a un peu subi des
revers ces derniers temps donc oui cette
question de la coopération est de savoir
qui est bénéficiaire
je dirais aujourd'hui les deux sont
bénéficiaires les deux sont
bénéficiaires mais ça ça va être jusqu'à
un certain point
c'est à dire à partir de quel moment
sachant qu'ils ne sont pas capables de
construire un projet commun autre que
apparaître comme une alternative
c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont en projet je
dirais en creux par rapport au projet
américain
on voit pas forcément finalement
jusqu'où ça va pouvoir prospérer prendre
de l'ampleur et attire et autres que
marginalement mais même déjà ce marginal
c'est suffisant parce que finalement
vous allez avoir de modèle le modèle
américain occidental
vous allez avoir ce modèle alternatif
qui peut quand même tenté beaucoup de
pays bon la turquie annonce qu'elle veut
elle aussi la turquie annonce dans le
même message que celui de félicitations
aux émirats arabes unis pour cette mis
en orbite autour de mars elle annonce
qu'elle va aussi avoir un programme
lunaire sauf que la turquie est
potentiellement plus capable d'être une
puissance spatiale que les émirats mais
si vous voulez bon la turquie peut être
intéressé à un moment ou à un autre par
les offres de la russie et de la chine
donc ça ça va être vraiment je suis
d'accord avec vous sur il ya des briques
technologiques russes qui sont encore
très très pertinente
surtout dans le domaine du militaire où
finalement la chine peut encore
apprendre en même temps la chine avait
une dynamique que n'a pas la russie donc
comme ce sont quand même deux grandes
diplomaties je pense qu'effectivement
ils vont essayer de maintenir au maximum
ce genre ce genre davantage très bien
j'ai passé aux cinq questions suivantes
parce que je vois que ton pass pour
commencer gilbert roger je vais essayer
d'être très rapide des questions plutôt
de conception européenne que vous avez
souvent évoquée je pense comme vous que
l'europe peut être été à sous-dotées ses
programmes spatiaux mais est ce que on
ne se rajoutent pas une épine dans le
pied dans le les espaces délai temps
qu'il faut pour prendre une décision
commune de travailler la deuxième
question que vous n'avez pas abordés
inconvénient pas inconvénient le départ
des de nos amis britanniques et donc du
break site jacques lemay pas oui merci
une question à la vie parce qu certains
redoutent une monopolisation de l'espace
par des entreprises quels impacts de
l'importance croissante de ces
entreprises privées dans l'espace et une
question isabelle survêt verger faire de
l'espace est devenu moins cher expliqué
thierry breton janvier dernier dans
quelle mesure cette affirmation était le
vrai et comment réconcilier faire de
l'espace et toutes les innovations et
découvertes qui en découle les enjeux
environnementaux
merci jacques nicolle duranton merci
monsieur le président donc merci
beaucoup
madame sourbès verger et messieurs et
monsieur pasco pour votre présentation
donc je suis élu dans le département de
l'eure et la ville de vernon et
pionnière en matière d'industrie
spatiale en effet emmanuel macron est
venu le 12 janvier dernier avec nos deux
ministres roi sébastien lecornu et bruno
le maire pour évoquer l'avenir des
filières de l'espace et de l'hydrogène
après la conception de fusées française
véronique et vestale site de vernon a
mis au point et fabriqué vikings le
moteur de la fusée européenne ariane
aujourd'hui transformé en campus de
l'espace le site de vernon regroupe
plusieurs entreprises dont ariane groupe
leader leader européen des lanceurs
spatiaux donc dans le cadre du plan de
relance
emmanuel macron a annoncé à cette
occasion donc investir 500 millions
d'euros dans le spatial dont 30 millions
d'euros pour le site de vernon + 2
milliards d'euros dans le plan de
relance ariane groupes qui utilisent
déjà de l'hydrogène pour la propulsion
des lanceurs ariane et qui viennent
conclure un partenariat avec l'énergie
siens angie pour produire de l'hydrogène
liquide d'origine renouvelable la
destination du transport maritime donc
et va bénéficier des aides de se prendre
ce plan de relance donc on sait que le
site de vernon est un site d'excellence
en matière de propulsion à l'hydrogène
15 millions sur les 30 millions sont
seront investis pour gagner
un an sur le projet promet tus donc
ariane groupe vise à développer pour l'
agence spatiale européenne un
démonstrateur de moteurs de fusées à bas
coût et potentiellement réutilisable
quand il ya plus de concurrence nous
devons mieux nous organiser innover
davantage donc avait déclaré le
président de la république en faisant
allusion à l'accélération de la
concurrence américaines et notamment ce
pass x et asiatiques dans l'industrie
spatiale
la société du milliardaire elon musc a
déjà recours à des fusées réutilisable
quand l'europe a reporté à 2022 le
premier vol de sa nouvelle fusée ariane
6 et s'interroge sur les technologies à
mettre en oeuvre pour la génération
suivante de lanceurs donc dans ce
contexte où les projets des landes musc
inclus de plus en plus le principe de
réutilisation
que pensez vous de ce principe comment
la france devrait-elle s'en saisir
comment garantir la souveraineté des
états sur les entreprises dans le cadre
de l' aventure spatiale qui produit un
grand nombre de données à caractère
confidentiel et exclusif et enfin pensez
vous que 500 millions d'euros soit
suffisant et comment mieux fléché donc
au mieux ces fonds je vous remercie mes
chers collègues je vous rappelle la
règle d'une question une minute s'il
vous plaît qui rompt pas une somme je
vais te rapide monsieur le président
parce que je crois je vais passer mon
tour
ma question avec avait trait à
l'évolution du droit international face
à l'arsenal isation et parfois la
rationalisation anarchique de l'espace
alors ça a été abordé rapidement savent
si nous nous interlocuteur veulent bien
développé voilà jeu sinon c'est je vois
la dernière question pour philippe
folliot en visio s'il nous entend
oui bonjour bonjour bonjour merci
monsieur le président juste un élément à
un élément de l'analyse de ma modeste et
meego l'espace est un peu à certains
égards comme le far west des temps
modernes avec que des règles qui sont
des règles même de type cloud avec un
cadre juridique qui n'est pas encore
tout à fait au camp complètement rétabli
avec des acteurs qui étaient acteurs
publics il ya maintenant des acteurs
privés des acteurs civils
d'autres militaires et donc avec une
nécessité j'avais d'ailleurs de prendre
en compte tous et tous ces éléments et
et le fait pour pour notre pays en
particulier pour l'europe en général de
deux tenues de prendre en main l
ensemble de ces éléments et c'est du
reste ce qui a guidé le fait de
transformer notre armée de l'air entre
armée de l'air et de l'espace et de
mettre le siège de de cette future armée
l état-major j'allais dire de cette
future armée de l'air et de l'espace en
l'occurrence à toulouse et donc je
voulais savoir ce que vous pensiez de ce
choix des éléments de déploiement par
rapport à la mise en place de cet état
major et de la nécessaire continuité et
complémentarité à trouver avec les
acteurs civils de l'espace européen
général et français en particulier je
pense au cnes notamment et est ce que on
regarde de compétences qui sont
peut-être parfois un peu limite est très
spécifique très spécifiques selon vous
n'y at il pas un jeu pour avoir un
certain nombre de deux d'acteurs
notamment du cnes qui pourrait jouer un
rôle aussi à certains moments pour notre
notre défense en étant des réservistes
de l'armée de deux de l'air et de
l'espace
donc pour pouvoir agir dans les deux
domaines à la fois dans le domaine civil
et dans le domaine militaire dans le
cadre d'une d'une intelligente si vous
me permettez l'expression mutualisation
des compétences et un philippe merci
cette dernière question je vous propose
qu'on se donne m un quart d'heure
maximum pour répondre comme ça
si oui alors je vais essayer de faire un
peu une réponse en synthèse là où c'est
possible oui sur la question que vous
évoquez des compétences croisées civils
et militaires en france
je pense que quand même c'est pas
effectivement un hasard si le
commandement a été installé la partie
opérationnelle à toulouse puisqu'il ya
quand même déjà la présence du cnes oui
la question de la réserve
je pense que c'est intéressant mais vous
auditionnerait sans doute d'autres
personnalités plus compétentes que moi
pour vous répondre sur sur le sujet bon
il est clair que il va falloir monter en
puissance et y trouver des nouveaux des
nouvelles forces vives mais je pense que
ça c'est ça doit faire partie chose
possible ma question la question que
vous évoquez sur le sur le far west elle
et elle est très intéressant parce que
je dirais d'une certaine manière elle
convient bien aux états unis ce que
cette image du far west
l'entrepreneur le chariot j'arrive je me
pose et se développe à tout compte fait
c'est un petit peu ce qui fait aussi
rêver lots de masques et c'est un peu ce
mythe américain qui est transposée dans
l'espace en réalité je pense qu'elle est
un petit peu excessive parce que le
droit international
en dépit de ces lacunes rang quand même
tous les états responsables des
activités dans l'espace et donc
finalement elon musk ne fait que ce que
l'état américain l'autorisent à faire le
problème c'est que ce que l'état
américain autorise à faire finalement
n'a pas de limites véritable en termes
de droit international et par exemple si
vous prenez cette affaire des
constellations l'autorisation par la fcc
américaine de développement de la
constellation oblige en quelques sortes
les iut à voir dans quelle mesure cette
constellation déjà autorisée va poser un
problème ou pas avec les autres puisque
l'union internationale des télécoms
gèrent les systèmes en orbite donc oui
le far west c'est en quelque sorte
davantage le fait que les lois
nationales
aujourd'hui ont du mal à trouver un
organisme régulateur pour en faire des
lois internationales et on voit bien
avec cette question des accords
multilatéraux que les états unis
essaient de faire par exemple sur une
zone de sécurité sur la lune qui pose la
question potentiel de l'appropriation
on voit bien les américains essayer de
faire un accord multilatéral qui du coup
deviendra en quelque sorte
internationale et c'est tellement
évident pour tout le monde que les
russes ont immédiatement opposé leur
véto de manière à éviter que par des
mécanismes de droit finalement ce
multilatéralisme deviennent par via la
coutume une règle donc donc ça je dirais
que oui il ya ce risque
laliberté dans l'espace ça fait partie
de je dirais du traité de 1967 aussi la
question c'est jusqu'où on préserve cet
usage de l'espace comme bien commun et
du coup ça me fait un petit peu la
transition que vous évoquez sur cette
question des enjeux environnementaux au
sens large parce que aujourd'hui on voit
encore assez peu la question est reposé
du conte carbone de l'activité spatiale
bon quelqu'un comme mais dans le meuse
qu'avec beaucoup de lanceurs
réutilisables etc etc des problèmes
potentiels on avait vu ça à une époque
dans les années 70 c'était assez étudié
avec l'avion spatial la question de la
manière dont on pourrait y avoir
potentiellement des aspects négatifs sur
l'atmosphère et c'est donc il ya une
dimension environnementale sur
l'utilisation de l'espace qui est encore
certainement sous traité on parle de
l'espace comme moyen de gérer
l'environnement thérèse parce qu'il nous
apporte des données ça c'est ça c'est
clair
jusqu'où il peut y avoir une approche de
durabilité peut-être plus qu
environnemental dans l'espace c'est une
très grande question qui à mon avis est
une question à venir et là par exemple
typiquement je dirais que c'est une
question pour les européens parce que
finalement c'est vraiment au coeur et on
pourrait avoir un nouveau discours et on
pourrait faire des propositions dans ce
domaine et trouver sans doute des as
sentiment assez large sur le plan
international puisque finalement c'est
un sujet qui va qui va concerner tout le
monde est donc puisqu'on fait rapidement
jeu du coup glissé vers la souveraineté
européenne
oui à la question de l'europe je
rentrerai pas malheureusement dans les
capacités en hydrogène de vernon parce
que ça dépasse largement mes compétences
mais c'est l'exemple même d'une piste
technologique sur lequel l'europe a des
compétences et qu'elle a tout intérêt à
valoriser
si on regarde là
question globalement de la souveraineté
européenne la vraie la vraie difficulté
je dirais c'est de s'entendre sur un
projet spatial commun les technologies
spatiales coûte de moins en moins cher
dit monsieur breton oui mais enfin il
coûte quand même encore assez cher et
par ailleurs s'il ya déjà deux
constellations américaine c'est à ça
qu'il pense quel peut être l'apport
l'intérêt est davantage une
constellation européenne
alors cet argument il avait été mis en
avant pour la navigation on disait les
européens n'ont pas besoin de faire
galileo parce qu'il ya déjà des russes
et les américains en réalité d europe 1
il a besoin de faire garder des os pour
des raisons d'indépendance et
d'autonomie
il est probable que ça peut être la même
chose pour les constellations
mais encore faut-il être capable de
trouver une autre cible de marché parce
que soit vous posez ça en question
d'autonomie et d'indépendance et dans ce
cas là il ya une vraie cohérence
soit vous posez ce en termes de marchés
et là on sait très bien que ce soient
les capitaux risques que ce soient les
conditions des faillites que ce soit
même les conditions d'échangé on
évoquait le break site qui va aussi
poser des problèmes qu'ils posent des
problèmes aux entreprises spatiale
européenne qui intégrer un volet un
volet britannique et qui font qu'en plus
maintenant l'agencé spatiale britannique
prendre l'ampleur et donc devient
potentiellement un petit peu
concurrentiel effectivement tout ça ça
suppose un accord politique mais on peut
voir le verre à moitié plein ou à moitié
vide et moi je pense que sur ces sujets
là on peut être positif et considérer
que l'europe vraiment avoir une voix en
tant qu'europe dès lors qu et c'est
quand même la grande question dès lors
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui est capable de
porter un projet politique spatial
européen et ça les instances
d'aujourd'hui elle ne s'y prête pas
tellement bien voilà pour faire très
vite et de manière assez sommaire
l'ama pour eux en fait pas mal reprendre
pas mal d'états étaient tes remarques
sur sur ces différentes questions pour
pour parler de l'europe effectivement je
pense que on peut vers le on peut voir
le verre à moitié plein et le verre à
moitié à moitié vide les délais oui
c'est l'europe l'europe l'espace pour
l'europe c'est d'abord ça a été un
vecteur d'identité commune en réalité en
misant sur sur l'excellence commune et
sur finalement un projet positif de
découverte de l'espace et derrière je
pense qu'à ce titre que se soit l'agencé
spatiale européenne dans un premier
temps et puis après plus dans le cas de
l'union européenne tous les efforts
spéciaux qui ont été faits avec les
flagships programmes sont ce qu'on
appelle copernicus ou galileo qui
s'appelle bien cité on a on a quand même
en fonction d'un investissement qui
reste un investissement bien en-deça des
investissements des grosses puissances
enfin deux des états unis en
l'occurrence aujourd'hui on a des
résultats en art câble avec une
industrie qui a contribué à consolider
l'industrie européenne ohmi heures au
meilleur niveau mondial et que vous
rappeliez madame la sénatrice soit vers
non aryens groupe ou d'autres fabricants
de 2,7 dans le domaine des satellites
aujourd'hui tiennent vraiment le haut du
pavé j'allais dire au plan technologique
le départ des deux là dans la grande
bretagne oui bien sûr c'est un j'ai déjà
dire c'est un élément important quand il
s'agit de mettre en place une politique
volontariste alors en même temps il faut
relativiser sans doute la place de la
grande bretagne a toujours été dans le
domaine spatial empreinte d'une grande
prudence
on va dire et avec finalement d'un point
de vue de contributions industriels dans
le domaine du lancement qui sont assez
ce qui était assez réduite donc
aujourd'hui que la grande bretagne se
reconstruit où se construisent à les
tenir hors du cadre européen
je pense que ça n'empêchera pas de toute
façon là l'établissement de relations
quand elles seront nécessaires et utiles
au o2 après je vois plutôt la
grande-bretagne - s'engager plus tôt
dans des coopérations et recentré ses
coopérations avec les états unis
évidemment peut-être avec d'autres
d'ailleurs
donc je pense que la politique spatiale
britannique la la montée en puissance de
la uk space agency correspond aussi à la
mise en place d'une politique on veut
dire aux diplomates six scientifiques et
technologiques nouvelles dans ce cadre
là le la monopolisation de l'espace par
les entreprises privées alors oui et là
je vais reprendre si ce que dit isabelle
en fait c'est vrai il ya cet aspect
alors far west et là encore je suis
d'accord avec ce qu'a dit isabelle
sourbès les états restent globalement
responsable des activités qui se tient
dans l'espace qu'on appelle la
responsabilité de l'état de lancement et
pour le coup le droit qui s'applique à
l'espace reste un droit public
international impliquant la
responsabilité étatique alors après
effectivement selon les lois spéciales
sur les autorisations données on voit
bien qu'on dont on on laisse un peu les
rênes sur le coup dans l'entreprise
privée et on lui on lui on lui transfère
un certain de responsabilité enfin une
fille née mais les flux d'argent sont
d'abord des flux d'argent public
cette activité de spe 6,7 sur activité
de spe 6 elle tient aussi au fait que
les états unis globalement dépense
beaucoup plus que les autres pays dans
le domaine spatial et donc à partir du
moment où on a du volume d'activité par
exemple la réutilisation
rien ne sert de réutiliser un censeur si
vous ne m'en sors ça sert à lancer des
charges
si vous avez peu de charges a lancé vous
n'avez pas ce cet attrait de faire des
économies d'échelle et c est de penser
volume vous pensez volume quand vous
avez beaucoup de charges a lancé et
aujourd'hui si on regarde le marché du
lancement marché du lancement c'est plus
de 100 lancements par an ça peut être
110 112 par an sur ses 110 ans 12 par an
la part commercial c est vraiment la
part d' où la concurrence se fait entre
les prestataires lancement concerne une
minorité de ces lancements les autres
lancements sonné lancements
gouvernementaux en général comme l'a
montré isabelle or selon les pays bien
sûr mais en général dévolu aux lanceurs
nationaux ou alors éventuellement au cas
par cas d'autres lanceurs si vous n'avez
pas et l'europe n'a pas fondamentalement
ce volume institutionnels de satellites
à lancer alors là votre perspectives en
termes de filières de lanceurs elle
change parce que construire un lanceur
que vous allez utiliser 5 10 fois pour
lancer cinq fois par an ça pose question
sur la filière donc il faut bien mesurer
ça alors je pense que bien évidemment
super six en particulier des falcon 9
ont mis la barre très haut en termes de
compétitivité en termes de deux coups de
réduction des coûts etc
je pense qu'il faut rapporter ça aux
types de missions qu'on fait c'est à
dire qu'effectivement si on a en europe
la volonté de de dégager du volume de
lancement il faudra que la filière
spatiale vraiment du coup si attac et
attaquent ce volume et fasse des
économies d'échelle si en revanche on
est sur des missions un peu moins
nombreuses plus pointus il faut sans
doute et c'est ce qui commence à être
fait penser alors là abaisser le coût
unitaire du lancement
et ça c'est tout les travaux
d'optimisation de de fabrication 3d etc
y compris pour le moteur prometheus par
exemple qui lui-même sera utile
réutilisables met donc en fonction des
missions je pense qu'il faut régler les
curseurs de manière particulière et je
pense et si je fais qu est-ce que ce
qu'isabelle disait in fine et ce qui
nous manque sans doute nous en europe
c'est une vision de ce qu'on veut être
en 2040 dans l'espace quelle est notre
position en tant qu'européens par
exemple par rapport à l'exploration
humaine par rapport à l'exploration
habitée
aujourd'hui nous européens nous avons
mis l'accent et je pense à juste titre
sur nous sommes les anges gardiens de la
terre copernicus c'est le grand
programme aujourd'hui qui permet de
suivre l'environnement on ne sait peu
mais qui permet de suivre
l'environnement terrestre qui permet de
faire le lien avec ses préoccupations
d'environnement globale etc
on a donc une europe qui est tourné vers
c'était l'expression lors de moins en
moins utilisée aujourd'hui mais l'espace
utile on dire voilà on va faire de
l'espace suite ils ont transité on
s'intéressait beaucoup moins à ces
questions de vols habités à ces
questions d'exploration humaine
d'ailleurs on n'a pas de lanceurs nous
qui finalement est adapté vous serez
qualifié pour lancer des humains on
pourrait le faire technologiquement on
l'a pas fait évidemment ça a été un
compromis qu'ils visitent aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit
qu'effectivement là il ya un cran qui a
été passée on commence à industrialiser
l'occupation de l'espace hockey et donc
on a aussi bien séméga constellation que
globalement d éléments de logistique qui
vont se mettre en place dans l'espace
terre lune globalement salué le
programme artemis le programme lunaire
sait moins c'est moi c'est important
j'allais dire pour ce que ça va faire
sur la lune que pour ce que ça va
produire dans l'espace terre lune avec
cette station sert comme une ère avec la
nécessité de faire des navettes qui font
des allers retours qu'ils déposeront des
astronautes qui feront du
réapprovisionnement de fioul et ça les
industriels
bien compris les musk les désosser les
autres ils se mettent je dire dans le
sillage de la nasa qui délègue des
prestations de services qu'ils achètent
des prestations de services des garde
fous témoin ce que je vous achète c'est
du ravitaillement de fret pour la
station circumbinaire vous faites comme
vous voulez vous me présentez vos offres
et moi je choisirais et on est de plus
en plus alors aux états unis dans cette
vision de logistique ce sont des
logisticiens qui sont en temps de
d'investir l'espace aussi bien peur pour
les infrastructure satellitaire que pour
ses infrastructures de services
d'intervention et c est ce qu on veut
être ça si on veut l'être nous il faut
qu européen on se détermine par rapport
à ça comment nous on peut se placer en
plus choisir de dire effectivement nous
on est sur nous l'espace utile sur c'est
très important je pense pour l'europe je
suis d'accord pour dire que c'est pas
assez exploité au niveau du discours
politique européen ça c'est majeur
d'ailleurs au passage l'administration
by dane est en train de le seuil de le
noter elle même et a remis encore ces
derniers jours de l'argent à la nasa
pour que la nasa reprennent pied dans ce
domaine de l'observation de
l'environnement thérèse du suivi de
l'environnement et c'est parce qu'il ya
un enjeu politique évident ça c'est
clair mais en même temps nous européens
on a besoin collectivement et c'est pas
simple de savoir ce qu'on veut faire
ensuite est ce qu'on veut faire partie
de cette grande
est-ce qu'on veut avoir notre accès
indépendant pour amener des hommes de
thomas pesquet dans l'espace et faire
est partie prenante d'une grande
architecture qui serait évidemment
américaine mais avec des aimants
d'autonomie ça c'est des vrais questions
parce que c'est ça qui ensuite va
décider de des choix technologiques qui
seront faits en matière de réutilisation
en matière de modernisation de finir des
lanceurs en matière de deux vaisseaux
habités et ça va structurer l'industrie
et et ça va créer ces économies ses
effets d'économie d'échelle c'est donc
ça je pense que c'est absolument
essentiel je pense que là on a un vrai
sujet de débat le public sur aujourd'hui
comment l'europe finalement c'est une
question c'est une non question c'est
une question que nous nous posons pas
nous avons une activité spatiale que
nous que nous poursuivons et on a raison
de le faire mais on arrive aujourd'hui
on est un petit peu sommet quelque part
par la situation en perdition qui évolue
que ce soit aux etats-unis en chine wire
nous mêmes de nous de nous demander quel
est l'objectif
comment se projette qu'est-ce qu'on veut
être dans l'espace et la meilleure
formulation que je puisse trouver
qu'est-ce qu'on veut être dans l'espace
je sais que c'est un voeu pieux que
c'est compliqué mais je pense que c'est
un vrai débat
deux sociétés de sociétés à l'échelle
européenne bien sûr avec difficulté ce
sera comme il a été dit est bien de
mettre en accord déjà déjà au sein des
pays des opinions publiques parce que
chacun voilà c'est un vrai débat vivant
et puis au sein des vingt-sept parce que
chacun des intérêts industriels etc
des projections j'allais dire d'image
national très différente dans l'ensemble
européen et a donc ça je pense que c'est
c'est très très très important et donc
quelque part l'espace far-west aussi et
bien c'est lié à tout ça c'est à dire
que évidemment l'environnement lui-même
il va il va être teinté j'allais dire
par le type d'activités qu'on va mener
par le type de de stimulation qui vont
s'y est aussi consacrée en terme
financier par le rapport public privé
est à nouveau j'insiste beaucoup il faut
il faut éviter de dante agoniser le le
développement de l'activité privée dans
l'espace ne se fait pas de manière
contradictoire avec vous ne se fait pas
ne s'accompagne pas d'un retrait du
secteur public en fait ce sont des
nouvelles modalités d'occupation de
l'espace par certains pays qui ont qui
définissent une nouvelle manière de
travailler que leur secteur privé qui se
met en place aujourd'hui avec
effectivement la nasa ne conçoit plus
les fusées les achète ça c'est très
différent mais sans la nasa ces
constructeurs et fusée devrait beaucoup
moins de sous donc on a cette volonté la
nasa se ressentent sur les jo et on a
une place plus grande qu'ils aient donné
une latitude plus grande qui est donnée
par le biais de lois nationales qui
elle-même du coup s'impose un petit peu
et on trouve peu de ce couple très bien
dans les dents les dents les les
principes internationaux qui existe
parce qu'effectivement ces principes
sont assez lâche c'est flou assez facile
à ces à ces plastiques finalement et
puis dernier point le droit
international sur la rationalisation
oui c'est certain on voit bien que là on
est en train un fait de certains disent
on est en train d'augmenter la cela le
globe terrestre on est en train de
monter en altitude clairement les
activités qu'on fait sur terre bien
tranquillement alors même si l'espace
est un milieu très particulier avec des
contraintes physiques et cédera donc
c'est purement cale un peu un peu
schématique ce jeudi mais il ya cette
idée que on est en train d'habiter
l'espace différemment en fait parce que
les technologiques comme hans altherr m
comment seulement elles permettent mais
là on a pour
décennies l'espace terre lune va devenir
l'objet central de focalisation de
l'ensemble des énergies des financements
etc
à partir du moment où on habite on my
cet espace différemment mais évidemment
on va vouloir protéger territorialisée
quelque part ça c'est là et notamment on
voit effectivement isabelle sourbès la
cité cette volonté de signer des accords
bilatéraux sur un règlement intérieur
sur les activités lunaire une fois
qu'elle s'y déploieront etc
on sort d'idron internationales se sont
d accord et ça c'est un vrai de vrai
nouveauté quelque part parce que bien
effectivement on va coexister donc on
commence à se mettre d'accord sur des
zones par exemple de sécurité veut sur
de l'interopérabilité entre ces zones et
ça et encore récemment la corée du sud
par exemple à signer cet accord je crois
qu'un autre pays vient de signer je
crois que c'est un accord qui compte
aujourd'hui huit ou neuf signataires
quelque chose comme ça et c'est de la
diplomatie alors là pour le coup active
c'est de la diplomatie active dans un
environnement qui est en train de
prendre une place importante et donc
pour le coup l'arsenal isation elle va
elle elle suit ce mouvement quelque part
il ya cette idée de on déploie de
l'infrastructure on protégera cette
infrastructure le rapport de force que
s'établir effectivement dans ce nouveau
milieu etc
alors là le droit actuel et bien
interdit qu'une chose c'est le
déploiement d'armes de destruction
massive en orbite mais ne s'interdit
rien d'autre donc aujourd'hui c'est très
très large bien sûr pas de militaires
sur la lune en revanche ça c'est quelque
chose qui reste quand même très fort
mais on voit bien que c'est quelque
chose qui qui va qui va donner lieu à
des discussions parce que il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de possibilités qui sont
laissées ouvertes quoi et le dernier
point que je voulais faire aussi sur les
régulations et un organisme très
important parce que ça va très vite qui
participa ca c est à l'étude de ces
régulations sur le trafic orbite alsace
et l'iso ce qui déploie donc
l'organisation des standards
internationaux qui sont extrêmement
actif en ce moment même dans les
discussions entre industriels pour
établir c'est ces normes
ces nouvelles régulations sur le type de
matériel qu'on peut déposer dans
l'espace états et les industriels sont
extrêmement attentifs à cela parce
qu'évidemment ça détermine une bonne
partie de leurs activités futures
voilà ce que je si vous aviez juste
vraiment deux secondes c'était pour dire
que ce que ce que reflète gravier passe
côte c'est tout à fait je dirais ce qui
est aujourd'hui la perception du saas
mais ça c'est une perception américaine
c'est à dire qu'en fait que font les
américains c'est qu'ils pensent l'espace
là vous l'entendez ils le pensent de
manière parfaitement cohérente et voilà
et que derrière ils font eux mêmes les
règles du jeu c'est à dire qu'ils sont
les premiers joueurs et ils font les
règles du jeu et vous avez beaucoup
d'étapes qui considère que le droit
international doit l'emporter et vous
avez quand même aujourd'hui cent et
quelques et à leur problème c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas de levier dire qu'ils peuvent
toujours on redira l'assemblée générale
des nations unies qui sont contre
l'arsenal isation de l'espace c'est à
dire la mise en place d'armes offensives
et ça ils le disent depuis un moment
s'est bloquée au copiaus par les états
unis
et l'histoire s'arrête là donc la
question et c'est là que moi je pense
qu'il faut rebondir sur l'aspect
européen on a essayé les codes de
conduite on a essayé des règlementations
pas trop contraignante mais est ce qu'il
faudrait pas essayer de penser aussi ce
vieux rêve d'une agence internationale
de régulation etc et qui ne serait pas
une agence de régulation par les
applications comme l'iso par exemple
parce que qu'est ce qui peut se passer
l'iso elle peut réguler plus les chinois
ils font ce qu'ils veulent et ça ça va
poser énormément de problèmes et donc
nous européens puisqu'on parle
enterrement c'est peut-être plus les
affaires étrangères que que la sécurité
et la défense mais la fondamentalement
beaucoup beaucoup de pays dans le monde
entier pense qu'il faut revenir à du
droit international et la dernière chose
que je voulais dire c'est qu'il ya le
droit spatial qui s'appelle d'ailleurs
droit des activités spatiales donc c'est
un petit peu différent et il y as
derrière toutes les régulations
classique que vous pouvez appliquer aux
régulations au milieu spatial est ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui dans le droit
c'est de plus en plus d'acteurs qui sont
des acteurs de droit international privé
et non pas publique
et ça c'est très intéressant et pour
revenir à la question des industries de
souveraineté
en europe on est en train de développer
ce concept d'industrie de souveraineté
d'un point de vue juridique incluant
incluant le spatial donc
donc je pense que cette image qu'on a
tous parce que les états unis ben voilà
sont la première puissance parce que
c'est eux qui avance parce que c'est eux
qui ont aussi cette masse énorme de
publications aussi antilles
fico technologie chercher en europe
combien nous sommes à travailler sur le
sur le spatial du point de vue des
sciences humaines et sociales
vous allez voir nous sommes quasiment
rien enfin j'espère n'est peut-être 4 ou
5 sur l'ensemble des pays européens
vous avez des écoles entières vous avez
des séminaires entier vous avez des
formations aux états unis qui font que
n'importe qui a une conception et quel
que soit son poste dans la société a une
approche des questions spatiales et ça
nous malgré tout c'est une grosse
vulnérabilité compris quand même
imaginer de corriger un peu et même
l'isu qui est installée à strasbourg et
l'international space university
c'est un truc amérique c'est à dire que
c'est vraiment pensé par des américains
sur un modèle de réseau américain même
si l'agencé spatiale européenne on est
un des principaux contributeurs
donc là moi je n'insisterai beaucoup sur
cette question là les européens nous
avons le poids suffisant pour peser en
terme de notre propre sécurité
notre meilleure garantie c'est quand
même d'être capable de proposer les
réglementations qui vont conditionner
cette garantie même si on doit pas se
leurrer sur ce qu'est le poids des états
unis dans l'espace mais je pense qu'il
faut aussi de se décaler un petit peu
par rapport à sa merci mais merci
monsieur le directeur ce tunisien était
passionnante vous êtes passionné on l'a
bien vu et nos collègues le nombre de
questions qui ont été posées par mes
collègues démontre tout l'intérêt qu'il
ya dans cette commission à aux enjeux de
l'espace qui sont des enjeux
considérables pour notre défense aussi
parce qu'évidemment aujourd'hui on est
extrêmement dépendant pour nos matériels
en tout cas une capacité militaire de
l'espace c'est un sujet que nous que
nous évoquons assez régulièrement
quant à l'état du droit effectivement on
a bien compris que les enjeux étaient
considérables qu'il fallait faire
évoluer le droit mais pourquoi je vais
j'avais prévu d'évoquer cette question
vous m'avez devancé mais c'est vrai que
dans une société dans un monde de moins
en moins ou le multilatéralisme de moins
en moins
la règle il va être extrêmement
difficile d'arriver à trouver un
consensus qui permettent à chacun de
respecter le droit international on voit
aujourd'hui combien d'endroits
international remis en cause quand on
est capable d'intercepter un avion
au-dessus d'un pays pour arrêter un
individu on comprend que il y à du
travail et du pain sur la planche comme
dirait l'autre en tout cas merci
beaucoup c'était très intéressant et
puis nous continuerons d'avoir un oeil
très très intéressés à l'espace merci
[Musique]